welcome to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast in this
episode Greg and I provide a thorough
report on the recent stronger by science
trip to Iceland after feats of strength
Greg and I discussed a recent paper that
has caused some controversy related to
the consumption of red meat and
processed meat after that we have a
practical discussion on how and wide to
implement D loads in your training and
finally Greg and I interviewed dr.
Michael Rea who tells us all about pain
science specifically in the context of
lifting weights as always thank you for
listening
we hope you enjoy
[Music]
all right welcome back to another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast I'm your host Eric Trexler today
I'm joined by a special temporary
co-host named Greg knuckles thanks for
having me on thank you for coming along
okay so if you tried to message Gregory
on social media in early October there's
a chance we missed it because we took a
big family stronger by science trip to
Iceland
very cool strength pilgrimage for
everybody listening if you want to go
pick up heavy stones on a beach or
potentially run into the strongest man
in the world Iceland would be the place
to do it
so Greg did you enjoy our time on the
trip oh yeah I mean it was sick very
cool place windy very windy extreme
dangerously windy but beautiful country
nice people windy to a point that
shocked me I had read a lot about
Iceland apparently no one talks about
how [ __ ] windy it is but it was it
was incredibly windy and with the intro
out of the way where we literally just
talked about the weather I would say
this episode is off to a smashing start
yeah so strong people rocks you can lift
glaciers and wind Iceland cool trip you
should go there now I did mention we ran
into the world Strongest Man I can think
of no better Segway than going to the
feats of strength segment hell yes so
the world weightlifting championships
were pretty recent about two weeks ago
at the time of recording this a few
listeners messaged me upset that I
didn't talk about any of the
performances there in our last feats of
strength segment so I will get on it now
so probably the headlining feat of
strength from the recent world
weightlifting championships is washa
talakad say went to 22 64 484 for the
biggest weight lifting total of all time
generally I convert to pounds but this
is weightlifting and so stays in kilos
because that's how weight lifting is
done and so his total of 484 is the
current world record and if you know
about weight lifting they redo their
weight classes from time to time mostly
just to wipe their record books
as testing improves and so recently
there there was a pretty big shift in
drug testing it got considerably better
around 2014-2015 a lot of people from
the 2008 and 2012 Olympics were popped
on retests I I recently saw this is a
little bit off topic but I saw an
article looking at the 94 kilo session
at the 2012 Olympics and I think to more
people in that session got popped on
retest recently so I'm pretty sure the
way it currently stands is like I think
the the person who initially placed
sixth currently has the gold medal in
that class and the person who plays like
eleventh now has bronze it was something
ridiculous like that like basically
everyone got popped anyway so drug
testing recently got a lot better
and so weightlifting redid their way
classes and so like there's there were a
ton of World Records set at the world
weightlifting championships but if you
go and check those World Records against
like the prior World Records at similar
weight classes you know for the most
part they're not quite back to where
they were before but lashes 484 is not
just better than the prior world record
but the old way classes which was also
washa
at 478 but it's the biggest weight
lifting total of all time the the
previous biggest for LA shows was 475 by
Taryn Yenko back in the 80s 1988 and and
people were kind of thinking that that
maybe
number that would never fall again
mainly due to drug testing like
weightlifting is still a pretty dirty
sport but they do at least have to be
clean on the platform not have drugs in
their system that will you know get
popped for in meat testing you know back
in the 80s there wasn't really any drug
testing whatsoever to speak of and so
people were like yeah
whatever like and if you look at other
weight classes as well a lot of times
the biggest number that has ever been
hit was hit in the 80s and then after
they restructured the way classes you
know new great lifters rose up but like
the 80s were kind of seen as the Golden
Age but yeah for 84 total biggest of all
time
biggest even counting like the Golden
Age of the 80s and Terry anko's record
that a lot of people thought may never
fall so again absolutely incredible
performance I think as clean-and-jerk
was like nine kilos off of his best so
if he shows up at the Olympics pissed
off he could he could conceivably total
500 kilos something like 225 to 75 600
or 500 I mean and that would just be
ridiculous anyway washa
very strong guy number two I'm gonna
mispronounce this name I apologize in
advance but Andre Sepang sykov Russian
lifter benched six oh six at 198 which
is 275 kilos at 90 kilos that was at a
big meet in Russia about three weeks ago
give or take and I just missed it as I
was doing my sweep for feats of strength
and so that's obviously a ridiculous
number if you go and watch the video it
looks like he still has a reasonable
amount of room left in the tank as well
which is ridiculous and I haven't seen
enough of his maxes to know if that's
just what a max looks like for him but
it's not he's not the type of lifter
where it looks like it would be a
so a lot of times people who are super
explosive benchers and especially big
benchers who lift with a relatively
close grip will have the bench style
where it flies up or it just doesn't go
at all that's not the style of bench
press he does so I do think he did
probably have some left in the tank
on that world record as well which was
awesome and just to put that in context
it's a 600 plus bench at 198 only a
hundred and thirty six people ever have
bench pressed six hundred plus the next
closest person to him in his weight
class only benches 562 so he has about a
40 pound lead on everyone else and so
you know he benches 600 plus at 198 only
three people have ever gone 600 plus at
220 the record is 617 so he's only 5
kilos or about 11 pounds off the 220
record at 198 which is ridiculous and
then only 11 people have ever bench 600
242 everyone else who's bench 600 plus
is 275 or above so of 136 people which
is a reasonably small group in the first
place only 15 of them are below 275
pounds and this dude's out here bench in
600 Plus at 198 it's like 22 pounds
lighter than the next lightest 600 pound
bench or super strong super impressive
and then to round out the feats of
strength for this week two recent feats
of strength from I I would say people
close to my heart as a lifter people who
were dominant lifters several years ago
as I was coming up in the sport who I
think may get overlooked these days so
the first is Dan Green back in I would
say 2012-2013 dan green was probably the
biggest and most famous power lifter in
the world he was the world record holder
in the 220 and 242 classes super super
strong guy right is right is like
untested
all Lifting was really coming into its
own he's since dealt with some injuries
few lifters have have risen up who have
surpassed him Yuri Belkin definitely
being the most notable but just based on
his training footage it looks like he
may be getting back into form and ready
to put some some sick lifts on the
platform most notably he recently dead
lifted seven ninety three four five and
that was without straps and if memory
serves he has had some grip issues on
deadlift in the past the most he's ever
pulled in a competition is eight twenty
seven so pulling seven ninety three four
five one is ridiculous no matter who you
are to is an all-time PR forum I imagine
as strong as he is all-time PRS are are
not easy to come by and three I mean it
looks it looks like his deadlift is way
better than it's ever been and if he
doesn't meet sometime soon he you know I
don't know if he would improve his total
but he definitely looks like he's ready
to pull somewhere in the neighborhood of
nine hundred super impressive super
strong and then also from the world
weightlifting championships recently
loose Alshon code old he went 171 207
378 in the eighty-one kilo class so
again that's a case where the current so
the 378 was a world record in the
81-kilo class this is a case where the
current record isn't quite as good as
the old record was so Lou had the prior
record in the seventy-seven kilo a class
at 380 so obviously 3 380 at 77 is
better than 378 at 81 but still like
pretty similar and the reason this is so
impressive is Lou won his weight class
he won the world championship it was his
fifth I believe but the thing is loose
thirty-five years old
I looked up the ages of the other male
winners at the world weightlifting
championships this year the next oldest
weight class winner was 27 so he was
eight years older than the next person
to win their weight class
in order to do so he beat his countryman
lead I mean who was the prior world
record holder in this weight class at
375 kilos at 81 and and so like I feel
like this was probably loose swansong he
I mean he's been at or near the top of
that class forever the 2008 Olympics if
memory serves was his big international
coming-out party
and he probably isn't going to represent
China at this weight class in the
upcoming Olympics just because like I'm
not gonna bore you guys with how
qualifying for for the Olympics and
weightlifting works but basically it's
like a cumulative thing it's not just
who has the best total in the weight
class and so Li has like a better body
of work up to this point during this
Olympia than Liu does so Lu's probably
not gonna make the Olympic team at 35 he
is considerably over the hill by
weightlifting standards doubt he wins
another big international meet at least
of this caliber but I mean this was this
is probably how he's gonna go out and
boy is he going out on top he was he
would I would say he and klokov were
like the most famous lifters in the
world 10 years ago klokov has been out
of the sport forever Lewis still winning
championships at 35 years old
super super impressive good for him like
I love to see it I'm still a fan of his
especially because he's been dealing
with a lot of injuries in recent years
so people were thinking that he was done
just period like two years ago extensive
injury history already 33 years old
people didn't think he was really going
to get back into form again especially
with you
other good lifters rising up in that
class yeah he he pulled another World
Championship out of his ass obviously in
pain but you just love to see it you
love to see it indeed okay now we've got
a research review segment and over the
last couple weeks there's been a lot of
buzz on the internet pertaining to a
recent nutrition paper the paper was
essentially looking at the health risks
associated with red meat and processed
meat and at the surface level it
appeared to give some contradictory
recommendations compared to what you
often hear in the nutrition literature
so the paper was called unprocessed red
meat and processed meat consumption
dietary guideline recommendations from
the nutrition recommendations consortium
this was published in the annals of
internal medicine and the lead author
was Bradley Johnston so this paper came
out and if you were to summarize the
findings in a sentence without a lot of
nuance basically they said you know your
red meat consumption your processed meat
consumption go ahead and just continue
doing whatever you're doing and that got
a lot of people fairly agitated what was
interesting this is one of those
journals that you see more often
nowadays journals are to some extent
expanding what they do in the online
space and so there are some journals
where you can actually access the
reviewer comments from each stage of the
review which is always fun to do in this
case the journal had like basically an
online comment comments section but it
was you know one step above like the
really ridiculous comments you see on
any typical website like the people that
leave comments they're in this journal
reading so it's usually people with some
kind of academic or public health
background theoretically theoretically
but in any case so there were some
really wild comments in the comments
section by this
for this article so you know you're
thinking this is the annals of internal
medicine it's a kind of physician
oriented medical journal right this is
physiology it's medicine and some of the
comments were wild so like one of them
was by deciding not to consider
environmental impacts of red meat
consumption this group has produced a
flawed report that is both an abdication
of the moral responsibility that is an
abdication of the moral responsibility
that physicians have to society so that
was like I was like yeah I I don't
necessarily disagree with the idea of
considering environmental aspects to
some extent in this conversation but
we're talking about a medical journal
here I do not want them practicing like
armchair environmental policy yeah and I
mean the the purpose of the study wasn't
you know in abs or like taking literally
everything into account what is the diet
that every person on the planet should
switch to for health but also for
environmental and socio-political and
economic reasons and everything else
like that that was that wasn't the point
of it it was just like health that's it
right yeah this is not the place to go
like on a deep dive of the ethics
related to consumption of meat or the
environmental impact I mean we're in a
medical journal
you know another comment again
physicians need to realize that climate
deterioration poses the most immediate
and grave risk to people's health so it
was another like long comment that was
getting into like let's make this whole
thing about the environment which again
environment pretty important but we're
in a medical journal so it seemed a
little bit out of place and then the
third one this one was interesting it
said even if conflicts are fully
disclosed not having vegetarian or vegan
panelists raises serious concerns of
inadequate viewpoint diversity leading
to unintentional distortion of the facts
the process of reaching consensus may
have progressed very differently if the
panel had balanced and diverse
viewpoints from meat-eater
flexitarians vegetarians in whole food
plant-based vegans so this was not a not
a criticism of the actual methodology
necessarily but really just a a request
to have more vegans in the mix so that
they could express their opinion yeah I
mean which doesn't make much scientific
sense to me because like so if the
argument is you know these people may
have had some level of bias and you know
maybe didn't consider some research or
maybe had issues with how they
interpreted some research that's that's
a perfectly reasonable thing to put
forth but typically in a scientific
discussion what you would then do is say
well it sure is curious that they didn't
consider this paper in this paper in
this paper which seemed to you know
contradict their bias may be that you
know there there is some clear evidence
of bias here based on you know how they
actually conducted their analyses in the
conclusions they drew from the evidence
you can't just say you can't just hand
weight it you know yeah you can't just
say like you know I'm not actually going
to do the work to see if they're bias
influenced what they had to say I'm just
going to like vaguely allude to the fact
that it probably did and hope people
don't think too hard about it yeah so
the argument would be like hey here are
some instances of bias not just like I
bet you would have read those same exact
results differently if you were a vegan
right because that's not a particularly
scientific basis of argumentation now I
will be fair they did something that
they used something called the grade
approach and grade is an acronym it's
the grading of recommendations
assessment development and evaluation
and so this is a method that is
basically developed for making it's
basically just for this type of thing
where you get a group of people together
you evaluate the evidence you try to
translate that into recommendations and
what it's supposed to do is have some
kind of additional acknowledgment of
how patients and the population will
value things and and what kind of
preferences they have it also puts a
pretty heavy influence on what are the
biases of the people doing the
evaluation both financial and
intellectual biases or conflicts so it's
not like those comments are 100% totally
out of left field
but if you're talking about like sliding
into the comments section of a policy
paper that involves five original
systematic reviews you would want to
have a more data-driven response to that
rather than say like well could have
been differently if people just felt
differently about the data they produced
you know so there have been some good
some good kind of open letters that
people have written where they have
raised you know different considerations
of like oh these criteria for this
systematic review were too strict you
should have included that paper you
should have included this in your your
analysis so there have been some good
data-driven or data based what's where
I'm thinking of criticism yeah there
have been some of those but what was
really striking was that the the
comments section kind of went totally
off the rails in at least like half of
the comments so this is a paper that has
generated a ton of discussion some of it
very evidence-based some of it not quite
as evidence-based but in any case what
they did here they got a group of people
together they did five systematic
reviews and then they tried to after
those five systematic reviews get
together and kind of take a vote on what
this evidence tells them and translate
that into recommendations so like I said
they used this great approach and a big
part of the great approach is that
there's a quality of Evon evidence kind
of scoring system that goes from high to
very low and what you'll see kind of all
throughout the paper even if you just
read the abstract I'm pretty sure it's
in there as well but they talk about
having low or very low quality evidence
and the grade system from what I
understand I've never used it obviously
but it seems like it automatically
favors randomized
controlled trials in terms of the
quality of evidence and tends to
penalize observational evidence and
that's a pretty important thing because
a lot of this research where we've
gotten our typical recommendations about
limiting red meat and limiting processed
meat consumption a lot of that stuff
comes from observational studies so when
a huge body of the evidence is that type
of research and you use this type of
scoring system a lot of people who are
critical of this paper kind of came and
said well you kind of knew before you
started that most of this evidence was
not going to carry a lot of weight based
on the scoring system so that's a pretty
interesting debate to have because you
know in most fields of health-related
science we do automatically accept the
randomized controlled trial as
essentially the gold standard of you
know evidence from which we try to make
inferences about causation nutritional
science really tends to stand alone as a
field of science where most of our
recommendations especially when you look
at like government panels that put
together that the big PDF reports every
five years a lot of it does seem to be
very heavily based on observational data
well I mean it kind of has to be right
to some extent yeah yes I mean you can
run a with nutritional science you
basically have three options you can
either run a really really tightly
controlled RCT for like two weeks
because it then becomes like super
burdensome and incredibly expensive to
do much more than that
especially like if it's inpatient and a
metabolic ward you can do you know like
a slightly less controlled randomized
control trial or like a considerably
less controlled one for a few months
where you you know assign people a
particular diet maybe give them some
counseling and have a way to check in to
try to make sure adherence is decent but
you know it's free living and you don't
know how good adherence is gonna be
those can run for a few months and then
you know if your injury
in health outcomes over like you know 20
years if people are eating a particular
diet like that's that's gotta be
observational research so like I mean on
one hand on one hand that evidence is
going to be inherently less reliable
like you can't necessarily extrapolate
the results of a two-week long super
tightly controlled RCT to health
outcomes over twenty or thirty years but
you can't you you also are gonna have a
really hard time ascribing causation to
observational research even if it's over
the long term with a lot of subjects
just because like you can't do that with
that kind of study so it it is
definitely difficult I mean in yeah the
the question then becomes like the RCTs
are theoretically higher quality
evidence but then in terms of the
outcomes you're interested in you can
run like a two-week highly controlled
RCT to look at you know changes in like
a particular biomarker with some sort of
change in diet but you can't actually
study the effects of those diets on
heart attacks because there's not gonna
be that many people that have heart
attacks in your metabolic ward in the
next two weeks I hope no yeah one one
one would hope one would hope so it's
inherently gonna be looking at proxy
measures which then also makes the RC
T's themselves you know good for the
actual thing they're assessing but since
what they're assessing is proxies for
the outcomes we probably care about it's
it's hard to know how much stock to put
in them as well yeah and so this
conversation is basically a microcosm of
the challenges of nutritional science we
want to know the answers to things that
if we measure the thing directly our
methods tend to suffer in terms of their
reliability and rigor
the only other option is to start
controlling things in a way that we
can't actually measure what we want to
measure and so this is why when a big
paper like this comes out you'll have
the camp of people saying oh we need to
start you know reevaluating how much
weight to put into this observational
study or that observational study and
then the people come and say but these
are the only studies actually looking at
that outcome and so this debate is going
to rage on forever and ever and ever
but basically what they if you look at
the purpose statement of what the
authors were trying to do here the way
that they present it is right now the
guidelines suggest limiting your
consumption of red meat and processed
meat but these recommendations are based
on observational studies that have a
high risk for confounding so they have a
limited ability to establish causation
and they tend not to report the absolute
magnitude of the effects that they're
observing and so that they also noted
that a lot of the organizations that
produce those guidelines they don't do
it systematically in terms of their
review process and they often fail to
address conflicts of interest
particularly well and so and they also
fail to account for the values and
preferences of the population so that
that's kind of the framework they laid
out for explaining why they use this
grade system did these systematic
reviews tallied it all up and then move
forward with some recommendations
okay now the methods it's kind of funny
because I did see some of the early
commentary online was like trying to dig
up conflicts of interests for these
people that like weren't reported or
something there's actually a massive
table in the paper purely dedicated to
conflicts of interest it includes both
financial and intellectual conflicts and
so what's really funny is in their
conflicts of interest table they they
estimated how much red meat they eat
over a given span of time so I did see
one person saying like oh this person
didn't report this conflict but it is
because they specified like within the
last three years and there was like a
conflict from like four years ago or
something like that but generally
speaking I think they try to keep it
above board in terms of conflicts of
interest because that was one of the
things that they wanted to to really
highlight with their approach I mean it
just as
note I really really like the idea of
disclosing intellectual conflicts of
interest just cuz like dude I'm not
gonna name names and start drama but I'm
sure you've come across this as well
there's there's quite a few people in
our field where if you read the title of
a paper and you see who the lead author
is you automatically know what that
paper is gonna say like and that
shouldn't be the case you know and yeah
I mean it's it's one thing to to take
money to promote a certain product or
idea but is that that different than you
know building an entire line of research
around a particular idea that you've you
know been promoting in the literature
and you know you using this concept that
you've been promoting in the literature
to gain promotion and tenure like you're
still you're still like tangibly
benefiting off of this thing you believe
like that's to me that's probably not
quite as severe as an actual financial
conflict of interest but I mean that can
clearly still influence how people are
going to design research how people are
going to interpret results I feel like
that's something that should probably be
disclosed more frequently yeah and I
mean I would also push back a little bit
to agree with you more than you agree
with you
so you mentioned like it's it's
theoretically like kind of a bigger
thing to take money for it but I would
argue that there are certain select
cases where the value of supporting the
hypothesis is more valuable than money
so like you'll you'll find instances
where researchers name a thing after
themselves you know what I mean and they
spend 25 years doing research on that
subject with this very established
metric or tool or theory that bears
their name they care more about that
standing the test of time in many cases
than they care about getting
$11,000 from some company yeah yeah for
sure so I think in some cases like there
are certain people that like have been
pushing like I mean you name it any
particular nutritional stance that it's
like do there's no evidence and they're
researchers but there's no evidence
that's gonna get them to say like yeah
my last 30 years of research probably
off-base yeah it's just not gonna happen
yeah for sure but in any case so whereas
with cotton with financial conflicts of
interest you know someone comes along
with a bigger check you can you can
maybe be a little flexible exactly yeah
so in any case yeah I do like the idea
though of disclosing some of those
intellectual conflicts like you said
there's there's a lot of people that you
just you see what the paper is about and
you're like well if it was bad they
wouldn't have bothered to publish it you
know there's no way they're gonna spin
this as a negative thing
yeah for sure okay so what they did here
was they put together a panel of 14
members including three community
members they were from a total of seven
countries and they voted on the final
recommendations after they reviewed the
five system systematic reviews that they
put together they noted in their methods
considerations of environmental impact
or animal welfare did not bear on the
recommendations so as a as a matter of
methodology they basically came out and
said we don't want to deal with
environmental impact we don't want to
deal with like animal rights ethics
stuff because we don't feel like that's
our place for this and so that's why
it's a little bit annoying when you see
like the the commentary saying but what
about the environment it's like they
very much told you on the front end we
don't want to do it we don't want to get
into it now if you want to read more
about this after you listen to it from
us obviously examine calm did a little
article that goes if you prefer the
written medium as well sometimes people
ask us for transcripts and I think Gregg
too earnest keep around here should
probably just type it up as he Ari
listens to it and just make those
available but in any case there is kind
a written article about this you're
making a pretty big assumption that I
read listen to this I'm sure you re
listening I don't I I put my my hot
takes out into the into the ether and
hope for the best
well I real issen to it like 30 times
gonna have to edit yeah I think that's
because the other day I have to prevent
you from making tragic mistakes and
causing beefs and getting us sued and
put in jail and stuff so I've only
broken federal laws on this podcast like
three times correct we're like 20
episodes in yeah okay I feel like one
legal transgression per seven episodes
it's not that bad it's not that bad okay
so they made these studies and by the
way when we're talking about red meat
we're talking about beef veal pork and
lamb stuff like that we talk about
processed meat we're talking about meat
that is salted cured smoked things of
that nature so just some operational
definitions there now the
recommendations get into the good stuff
the authors the panel kind of took their
vote and the panel suggested that adults
continue current unprocessed meat
consumption they considered that a weak
recommendation with low certainty
evidence they also suggested that adults
continue their current processed meat
consumption again it was a weak
recommendation with low certainty
evidence the votes on for both of those
recommendations were 11 votes to
continued consumption with three votes
for a weak recommendation to reduce
consumption of red meat and processed
meat so that's how the tally went down
and I think one thing that's important
to to consider here is when they did
these systematic reviews you know they
did these five reviews and generally
speaking the results of the individual
reviews kind of pointed toward weak
evidence showing a modest benefit of
reducing intake of red meat or processed
meats so a lot of people saw the
headlines for this paper and we're like
oh my god a huge sea change in the
nutrition research I don't think that's
a fair characterization of what the
study found and actually I don't think
the authors
that's a fair characterization because
they did mention that there recommend
recommendations do not seriously
challenge previous recommendations
basically what they were trying to get
across here is you know obviously based
on the scoring recommendations as we
mentioned a lot of this observational
research they would consider of
relatively low rigor compared to a you
know controlled trial so that bear is a
big that has a big bearing on
considering it to be low certainty
evidence based on the scoring system but
I think what they're trying to get
across is we have some of this
observational evidence of modest health
benefits I think when they included some
of the preferences and values of how
people view reductions or really just
any kind of drastic change to their
dietary habits I think that is probably
what tipped them in the direction of
saying yeah there might be some benefit
but it kind of seems like a pain you
might be fine if you just continue your
thing probably won't hurt if you reduce
it but whatever I think that's pretty
much where they ended up with their
recommendations and the author's note
they say for the majority of individuals
the desirable effects which they note
are a potential lowered risk for cancer
and cardio metabolic outcomes but they
said you know those desirable effects of
reducing red meat consumption or
processed meat consumption as well they
probably don't outweigh the undesirable
effects which they consider to be impact
on quality of life the burden of
modifying those meal preparation and
eating habits and they basically say you
know they gave this weak recommendation
but they do acknowledge that people's
values and preferences do differ a lot
and you know individuals who are fully
informed about the risks of consuming
red meat and processed meat they may
very well choose to limit that
consumption and if they do I'm going a
little bit off their words here but I
think it's safe to conclude if you were
to reduce that red meat and processed
meat consumption all other things being
held equal it would probably have
negligible to a modest positive effect
on your health outcomes I think that's a
pretty fair thing to say I think the
authors of the paper would agree with
that
so really the what this paper brings to
the table in terms of challenging
previous recommendations is they just
kind of downplay the certainty and the
magnitude of the effect where I think
earlier recommendations would would have
have you believe that you know even the
slightest reduction in intake of red
meat or processed meat would have a
tangible large meaningful effect on your
long-term health outcomes I think they
are of the opinion that those
recommendations probably overstate the
certainty that we have and the magnitude
of the effect and they fail to account
for the fact that a lot of people
probably don't want to change that
particular aspect of their diet yeah
that makes sense so I mean as with most
things that it just comes down to how
one assess costs and benefits you know
and I mean even if they found a large
effect it's still like a cost-benefit
analysis if so like for example just
using myself here when I first learned
about you know the effects of especially
processed meat potentially on cardio
metabolic health outcomes there's
there's a pretty big history of heart
disease in my family and so like I still
like steak still gonna eat steak you
know I like meat in general I eat a fair
amount of it but especially since it
seems that the process meat is likely
more deleterious and the red meat if if
one or the other does does have that
effect when I learned that like I did
cut back quite a bit on how much like
sausage or bacon
I ate growing up we ate a lot of sausage
and a lot of bacon and you know for me
that was those were relatively easy
substitutions to make
you know if I wanted to if I would have
had like sausage and eggs for breakfast
you know if I've prepped chicken
beforehand I'll just like cut the
chicken up throw it in a pan
toss some like sage and rosemary in
gives it kind of a salsa G flavor it's
not as good as sausage but like it's
probably a better alternative and that's
like a relatively easy substitution for
me to make you know but it's like it's
it's also not something where like I'm
going to stop consumption of all sausage
and bacon in perpetuity forever you know
and so like if if the effect were larger
I would probably eat even less if the
effect were smaller I might still be
eating more sausage and bacon to me that
seems like for myself and how is s risk
an appropriate way of dealing with
evidence that's out there but you know
like if you're like a ray kurzweil
acolyte and you're trying to live as
long as possible until you meet the
singularity and you know you want to
extend your lifespan by any means
necessary
a small possible effect that may be
worth making large changes for and
saying like well [ __ ] it I'm never
eating bacon again don't know for sure
this is gonna do something bad to me but
it might
and since my only goal is longevity at
any cost pasta or at any cost
imaginable you know it's worth it to me
to cut bacon out of my diet forever or
like you know if you're a [ __ ]
nihilist just just taking a Yolo
approach to life you like bacon make
sure in your life a little bit but
goddamn it you like bacon and you're
just gonna eat a bunch of bacon you know
yeah I mean it's it's a very fair
approach to these types of things and it
seems quite intuitive you know there was
there's a guy named David Katz at Yale
and he's a big plant based nutrition guy
I don't necessarily agree with all of
his takes on nutrition but I I believe I
remember seeing him right in
article while back that the whole like
thesis of it was like hey let's let's
use what we know and I think when it
comes to nutrition we have some things
figured out but there are some things we
haven't figured out you know I there's
that those research questions on the
horizon that we're still trying to
figure out and the body of literature is
a slow-moving ship you know it kind of
continues moving forward slowly it's not
particularly nimble but we're still just
hammering out those additional details
study by study but I think a lot of
people resent that idea and don't have
the patience to watch it pan out and so
a lot of people I think are drawn to the
the opposite of that which is what if we
took everything we knew threw in the
trash flip the paradigm and found this
one quick like trick you know so like
these these very fringe diets that say
like what if the whole secret all along
was blank filling whatever you want I
mean dude I I think that's how most
people are trying to interpret this
paper so I will admit to not having read
this yeah I could not possibly care less
about a topic just throwing that out
there but I mean I saw a bunch of people
sharing articles about this study or
just like posting about it on social
media yeah and you know the majority of
my timeline is it's like some sciency
people who are also meatheads and then
just like straight up meatheads and
literally the only take I saw about this
paper the only one the only thing I saw
literally anyone saying is ha like suck
it vegans I'm gonna eat as much red meat
as I want science says it's fine no risk
whatsoever
get [ __ ] like like that would that was
the only take I saw anywhere on social
media which is which is exactly what
you're describing like it's yeah I mean
where are we not discussing this right
now I would have no idea what the actual
page
per said because like that's that's the
only take I've seen about the paper so
yeah I mean yeah so people like that
idea of let's dump what we know out
latch on to a completely alternative
paradigm and hope it pans out and people
have done that with every nutrition
trick in the book especially if it
justifies your biases absolutely so in
the light of this paper and all the
headlines is generated and all the
discussion I think it is a good
opportunity to go back to what do we
feel like we know about nutrition there
are some good things good things would
include eating a whole bunch of fruits
and vegetables with fiber eating some
good fibrous grains mixtures some dairy
and seafood and legumes and nuts and
seeds the stuffs pretty good lean meats
tend to look pretty good from a health
perspective stuff you want to keep an
eye on very excessive intakes of
saturated fats added sugars you know
refined starches processed meats that
doesn't mean you can't have some of them
it means that generally speaking those
are the things that when we look at the
totality of the literature there are
some studies saying hey maybe just keep
an eye on this keep it within a low to
moderate intake that shouldn't be a
particularly controversy controversial
position to hold
I'm not demonizing any one of those
particular things but it means in the
context of a complete diet they should
not dominate the diet and they should be
skilled in proportion to overall energy
balance and a great example of that is
for most people the recommendation to
reduce excessive added sugars and ultra
processed carbohydrates that's generally
a good idea but if you wanted to look at
who's consuming the most of that stuff
it's probably some of the healthiest
people in the world it's people that do
a whole bunch of endurance training and
as long as they're not exploding their
hearts because I know there's some like
long-term like really extreme endurance
athletes actually are not the healthiest
people in the world so I walked right
into that trap but I knew you're gonna
call me out for that
but you know people who do a whole bunch
of endurance exercise recreationally and
are of good body composition and are
just using those carbs to fuel their
workouts they tend to have very very
good health outcomes in the long term so
you have to contextualize this stuff but
but like I said generally speaking a
diet that has excessive energy and tends
to be dominated by saturated fats added
sugars refined starches and processed
meats it's probably not the best idea
you want to keep an eye on those things
and keep them moderate in terms of
intake stuff to avoid trans fats and
excessive alcohol intake that's kind of
what we know here and I don't think this
paper makes a meaningful splash in terms
of turning any of those concepts on
their head you can get into the
nitty-gritty of exactly how much
saturated fat should be taken in exactly
how risky processed meats are but
generally speaking what they're saying
is hey all things considered equal yeah
there probably is some kind of you know
modest risk associated with super high
intakes of either of the two most people
don't really want to change it's kind of
a cost-benefit thing now with red meat
and processed meat some of the things to
keep in mind is like well if they're
problematic what exactly is problematic
about them and there are a couple ways
to look at it first you could look at
you know one of the struggles with diet
studies in general especially
observational ones is we have to
consider whether the presence of one
thing is what's problematic or if it's
displacing other things from the diet
and mathematically you can try to suss
that out but you know one thing to keep
in mind is when we do these
observational studies and we see a diet
that's super high and you know fatty red
meats and processed meats there it's
probably not like what do you have for
breakfast well I have a nice spinach and
tomato salad and nine pieces of sausage
that's not how those meals look so you
have to consider from an observational
perspective to what extent are we seeing
these things
as being causative of issues and how
would that differ in the context of a
generally complete diet you know because
a lot of times eating more if one thing
means you're eating a lot less of other
things so I would imagine that well in
its it tends to be even more confounded
now I mean I think I think I would
probably have more faith probably in the
initial data set that the
recommendations to limit red meat
consumption were based on because like
general so you know for 30 40 years
we've been told eat less red meat eat
less processed meat and so generally
like the people who hear that and take
that seriously and then proactively try
to reduce red meat and processed meat
consumption are probably also people who
will take you know other bits of advice
that they perceive to be healthy and so
you know people who consume less red
meat less processed meat also tend up
lower rates of smoking also tend to have
a lower rates of alcohol consumption
generally get more moderate to vigorous
physical activity like meeting activity
guidelines and so like at this point
kind of what you're getting at like if
you if you use like a modern data set
you can try to statistically control for
a lot of this stuff but it's it's going
to be a big confounded mess whereas
before there was the negative perception
of oh like red meat saturated fat that
might be causing issues I feel like that
would probably be a less confounded data
set but I also think you would raise a
lot of reviewers eyebrows if you're like
hey I'm trying to publish original
research based off of an archival data
set from the 1960s you know yeah so it's
it's def it's definitely tough and
because there is the interaction between
like government and like public
recommendations and people's behaviors
and how health behaviors cluster it's
it's more confounded now that those
recommendations have been out there then
it would have been where those
recommendations never made so it's it is
varied
difficult to study big-time yeah because
you're not just looking at the intake of
that thing you're looking at all of the
habits and behaviors associated with
what happens when a person or a person
who eats a lot of those things what else
do they eat what else do they not eat
and what other health-related behaviors
do they engage in so that that's it
makes it really challenging for sure and
I don't think there's a really good way
around that aside from just continuing
to develop our research methods and
statistics to become more and more
nuanced as we go now with red meat and
processed meat looking at potential
causative issues of how they might
deleterious ly affect these cardio
metabolic outcomes and cancer risk a lot
of things that come up polycyclic
aromatic hydrocarbons heterocyclic
amines nitrosamine x' and other end
nitroso compounds when you look at some
of these things that are that are
potentially driving some of these
negative health issues aside from just
the the energy and the fat content as
well one thing you can keep in mind here
is there are potentially ways to
minimize that risk with how you prepare
the food and what you eat it with and so
my takeaway when I look at a study like
this is you know when we look at the
totality of the evidence it does seem as
if there's at least a small to moderate
risk associated with super high intakes
of fatty red meats and processed meats I
think you can potentially it's no one's
ever going to be like ah you know my
health took a really negative turn once
I stopped eating sausage and bacon it's
probably not going to be the case so it
would be prudent to at least incur at
least approach that from the the mindset
of aiming for moderate intakes you know
at most but also you have to consider
how you're cooking them and I think it's
I think there's evidence to suggest that
probably what you don't want to do is
scorch the hell out of them and probably
what you don't want to do is consume
them
in the context of a diet that's
generally low in fiber and antioxidants
I think that by managing the cooking
procedures and by managing other aspects
of the diet and the meal in which
they're consumed to promote more
antioxidant and fiber intake I do think
there's high potential to at least
attenuate that risk to some extent yeah
so one one other thing I would note as
well is if you if you are planning on
especially grilling meats one of the
things that that has been looked at in
the research previously is the effects
of prior marinating on nitrosamine
formation during the grilling process
and so you you can't fully mitigate it
but you can to some degree mitigate the
effects like the negative effects of
high heat cooking methods by marinating
your meat first
and also I mean marinating is great so
you know that's a that's a combined
health and culinary tip if you marinade
your meat it's probably gonna be tastier
probably gonna be juicier and probably
is going to be a little bit healthier
for you if you are planning on using a
high heat cooking method definitely yeah
so just to wrap things up a little bit
as it pertains to this because I know
Greg's bored out of his mind until until
we talk about grilling listen I've said
some things that might sound as though
I'm like you know anti animal fat anti
red meat anti processed meat those
aren't really true and I do I do believe
that we've probably demonized animal
fats more than we should have in
previous decades of nutrition research
but that doesn't mean to go the complete
other direction and be like I'm gonna
have a diet that's you know seventy
percent animal fats there's nuance here
so I think it is prudent to have some
some semblance of control over your
intakes of fatty red meats and processed
meats I think low to moderate takes with
intakes would be advisable
and I think it like you said if your
only goal your only goal was to
construct a diet that was going to
promote your health and minimize
long-term disease risk and mortality
risk I think it's hard to suggest that
you would have any diet other than one
that is a pretty heavily plant-based
with sufficient protein to get the job
done but you would not be eating a diet
that's extremely high in red meats and
processed meats that were cooked at high
temperatures there's no way you would
justify that for sure one of the funny
things actually is the the very small
handful of times that I've like stuck my
toes in the nutrition waters one of the
pieces of feedback I get is like just
how different nutrition recommendations
for living forever versus getting huge
are so you know we look at something and
it's like oh this this stimulates the
mTOR pathway and this causes an increase
in igf-1 those things both sound awesome
let's get more of that and then like the
longevity folks those are two of the
main things they look at for the
opposite reason it's like let's keep em
tor as [ __ ] low as possible
and let's try to get igf-1 through the
floor because I mean essentially those
are things that are going to be
associated with cell growth like muscle
cell growth but then also like
initiating and progressing along the
cell cycle and like cell turnover so you
know you're you're going to just like go
through your stem cell lines a little
bit faster and age quicker if I GF 1 and
M tor high all the time and so like you
want to get jacked
like that's maximizing jacked miss and
maximizing longevity there there's to
some degree it's related like if you if
you look at the research on like lean
mass or or muscular strength when
someone's like 60 that's a reasonably
strong predictor of like subsequent
lifespan but a lot of that can probably
just be accounted for by is someone
generally active or not
so there is certainly some relationship
between being at least somewhat jacked
and living in a while but like trying to
maximize hugeness and maximize longevity
those are inherently contradictory
things just because like the signalling
pathways associated with them are
literally opposite yeah yeah that's it
is funny when when you look at the
longevity research I've had to do that
in the past for coursework and yeah you
see like you know big big increase in
mTOR activity and you're like oh cool
and then the next sentence is like this
was a disastrous intervention here leo
[Laughter]
but yeah so you know wrapping things up
I kind of view this thing like the old
debate about like post-workout protein
and a lot of times people are like oh
it's it's maybe not that big a deal to
have it immediately but then the other
question is like what does it hurt to
have it like why would you intentionally
delay that unless your stomach just
can't handle a post-workout meal you
know it's almost like viewing it as the
null hypothesis is like yeah it's
probably a good idea if you're trained
and trained and really hard get some
protein after that makes sense
and I kind of view it the same way with
with red meat and processed meat intake
when you look at the literature it's
either gonna have a negligible -
potentially slightly deleterious effect
so all other things considered equal if
it doesn't hurt you to remove it in
terms of like you know if it's something
you're not going to horrific ly miss
from your life it probably makes sense
to keep an eye on it and keep it at a
low to moderate intake if you absolutely
love it to the extent that you don't
care about the health risk your
decisions already made up I'm not gonna
try to talk you out of that but I think
that understanding of how to approach
red meat and processed meats is very
consistent with the most recent paper of
listen if you're not gonna miss it it
probably you're never going to regret
limiting it from a health perspective
the question of exactly how deleterious
is it it's
still a little bit up in the air and up
for debate but we're certainly looking
at something that either has negligible
effects or slightly negative it doesn't
mean we have to demonize it it doesn't
mean you can't have some of it in your
diet
it just means let's take a moderate
approach it's not at all at the place
yet I don't think where we would like
with trans fat no one is on Team trans
fat like I found for the most part are
there people that are on Team trans fat
no no I mean there are so so most of the
like industrially produced hydrogenated
oils nobody's on Team hydrogenated oil
yeah I was just gonna throw out there
that like CLA is a trans fat right yeah
yeah it is
but yeah no one is on Team hydrogenated
oils yeah I don't think red meat is
anywhere near that yet I think red meat
generally has a better track record than
processed meats if you're not going to
miss it it's probably a good idea to
keep them at low to moderate intakes and
that's not super controversial and
that's not necessarily conflicting with
this most recent paper okay so now we've
got a coach's corner segment about D
loads and D loads are I find them very
interesting because I think there's a
lot of variation in how people approach
them it's a question I get a lot from my
clients when they first start working
with me is what a deal ODEs look like
how often are we going to do them why do
we do them and it's it's always cool to
see different perspectives of how people
handle D loads in the process of
programming for themselves and for a
client so I really want to figure out
how Greg approaches them first and then
talk a little bit about how I do with my
clients so Greg D loads first of all why
bother so that's a good question and I
think there are two potential different
answers to it so one is just and I think
this is probably the most the most
reasonable reason to like program D
loads like say you know six weeks from
now we are going to take a deal ode is
just kind of as a prophylactic
just like a better safe than sorry type
thing you know because you try to write
training programs that are going to be
you know reasonable volumes intensities
frequencies whatever like a training
load that people can recover from but
you know sometimes you get volume too
high sometimes people have life
stressors going on that come up up out
of nowhere and you know a training
program that should have been
appropriate that someone could recover
well from you know now it's a little bit
too much and fatigue starts accumulating
and you know if it accumulates for six
months you might really run into issues
but if it accumulates for a handful of
weeks they might feel a little worn down
but they're probably gonna be fine so if
it's a situation like that especially if
you're just putting like a general
program out there into the world and
you're just trusting that people will do
it and not [ __ ] it up or you know
sometimes with like a distance coaching
relationship where you know it's not
like in-person coaching where you're
gonna be seen and talking to the person
multiple times per week and being able
to get a good read on them you know it's
not a bad idea to program D loads every
depending on the person maybe every four
to eight weeks just as a prophylactic
like you're not going to miss out on
that much by taking an easy week of
training but you know on the the
non-negligible chance that maybe they
are starting to accumulate a fair amount
of fatigue that's going to give you a
chance to knock that down make sure
they're you know in a band of stress
that they can recover and adapt
positively to so I think that is I think
the main reason for using proactive D
loads then personally I prefer in my own
training reactive D loads where instead
of saying I'm gonna deal out every six
weeks no matter what I say I'm going to
train in such a way that I think is
appropriate try to match
a training stress to my recovery
capacity and then if I [ __ ] that up I'll
take a deal owed so you know if things
are going well I'm sleeping well I'm not
making dumb decisions with my training
maybe I'm not gonna deal owed for a year
at a time or you know if I do the load
it's just - you know taper for a meet or
something but you know if [ __ ] hits the
fan work-wise I have just a random week
of insomnia which happens from time to
time then it's like okay I'll do a deal
owed I didn't plan to do to do this deal
owed but I'm feeling worn down I'm
feeling fatigued I need a deal owed I'll
take a deal owed so yeah there's there's
proactive and reactive D loads I tend to
favor reactive D loads if you're
coaching yourself and you have and
you're decent with being honest with
yourself and listening to your body's
feedback or if it's like an in-person
coaching relationship where you know you
can communicate with the person you're
seeing them multiple times per week you
can kind of get a vibe on like how
they're moving how they're feeling so in
those situations I tend to favor
reactive D loads certainly for just
putting like a general program out there
in the world where you hope that people
do it and don't [ __ ] themselves up or
for a lot of like distance coaching
where you you can get feedback but it's
probably not going to be especially like
the subjective feedback of just like
just seeing the person and being able to
get a read on how they're feeling I
think the more proactive D loads make
more sense in those situations and so a
d loader are you pretty much always
using a one-week duration or is that
flexible it's flexible um so I don't
know it depends for reactive D loads
it's just like however long I need
mm-hmm generally it's like three days
maybe oh okay I mean just because like
dude unless unless I did some really
stupid [ __ ] I should be able to recover
from just about anything in three days
like that's that's a long time
especially for someone who's you know
reasonably well trained theoretically
they have like repeated bout effect
adaptations to their muscles and nervous
systems so they're hopefully not going
to be able to get too [ __ ] up in the
first place
so yeah I mean generally I think that
for most people most of the time
somewhere between three and five days is
probably sufficient but also people I
mean we live in a world that runs on a
seven-day week and so seven days isn't
that much more than three to five days
if you accidentally put if you push your
D load two days longer than you needed
to push it that's fine
like your that's probably realistically
one training session and if you take one
more easy training session than you
needed to that doesn't cost you anything
you know so yeah I don't think I don't
think having week long D loads is a bad
idea
I don't Jenn I don't think it's
generally necessary but you know it's
that's probably a good better safe than
sorry
length of a deal owed and so when you do
a deal owed I've seen people kind of
propose different approaches to it some
people just don't train some people
drastically reduce their volume some
drastically reduce their intensity what
does a D load actually look like for you
so to me I think I think it's important
to keep the purpose of a deal owed in
mind and I'll note that a D load is
similar to a taper but it's not exactly
the same thing as a taper it's you know
certainly ideal if you feel good at the
end of a deal owed and that also
coincides with performing better because
you're less fatigued but you know in
general after a D load you're not trying
to hit your best one rep Max's ever the
first session back from the D load so
that differs from a taper where you know
you probably do need to keep
you know somewhat reasonable loads
moving just so by the end of it you're
you're not d trained and you're able to
you know put it put a good total in the
platform so with a D load I think again
it it kind of depends on the person and
it kind of depends on why you're taking
the D load in the first place and it
depends on how that individual reacts to
different training stressors and so if
if it's someone who so like using myself
for example intensity doesn't really
bother me like just I think from doing
Bulgarian style training for a while
like I can hit a 1 rep max and if that's
all I do in that session the next day
I'm gonna feel like I did nothing
whereas like hitting the true max and
training may really cause a lot of
fatigue for someone else but for me like
if my volume gets reasonably high that
[ __ ] me up and really really wears me
down whereas for other people they do a
bunch of volume in less intensity so
they could do more volume and that one
it affect them as much so it's going to
kind of depend on what training variable
causes the most subjective stress to
someone so for me if I'm taking a D load
that means volume is gonna come way down
generally intensity is gonna come down a
little bit as well but for me the most
important variable is volume for someone
who is more affected by intensity but
you know their their volume capabilities
are great and higher volumes don't cause
as much fatigue for them for them a deal
owed is absolutely going to involve a
big reduction in intensity and probably
a little reduction in volume as well but
intensity is the the main variable you'd
want to make sure you bring down and
again if you just want like a
middle-of-the-road approach reducing
both is fine you know something like
dropping intensity 15 20 % and volume 30
to 50% that's probably gonna make for a
pretty decent D load for most people are
there any instances where you would just
take time completely off so III think
the answer to that kind of depends on
practicality and more than any
thing else I don't think it's like
quote-unquote optimal theoretically to
just take time completely off of
training but at the same time again it's
like and I I think it depends on like
how frequently you're doing it so for
example if you're doing a program where
you do three weeks of training and then
D load on the fourth week so like a 531
esque setup you probably don't want to
take a quarter of your total training
time completely off of training yeah
that's probably not ideal but you know
if you have a setup like that and you
you know do like a more typical D load
where you know you drop volume and
intensity a little bit and so it's
basically like you have three hard weeks
in one easy week and you do that for a
few months and then on the fifth month
you're like you know what I'm feeling
kind of burned out I've been seeing way
too much of the inside of a gym I just
want to take this week off that's fine
you know like taking a week off of
training every four months six months
whatever like that's that's not gonna be
the end of the world
so unless you're doing that like all the
time I think it's probably fine again
it's probably not like the best thing to
do it's not theoretically optimal but as
long as you know as long as you're not
taking like a week off every month
you're probably gonna be okay
do you recall seeing any research I
could have sworn I saw at least one
paper like this but it was with fairly
untrained people but they they used like
pretty periodic weeks off have you ever
seen that research where they compared
continuous training versus people who
just like train for a little bit of time
and then just stayed away from the gym
and it was kind of like an intermittent
thing like that yeah so there are
actually a couple studies on that the
lead author for for both of them is agha
so whare and the way that those studies
worked is essentially one group would
just train continuously and the other
group would train six weeks on three
weeks off and those three weeks off were
just three weeks off off
and what they found is over a pretty
reasonable length of time I want to say
one of the studies ran 15 weeks and the
other maybe ran 21 weeks or something
like that the group taking periodic time
off ended up having similar strength
gains and similar hypertrophy to the
group training continuously one thing to
note is those studies were on untrained
lifters so you know I pray I don't think
it's probably ideal to take a third of
your time completely off training if
you're ten years into the game and still
trying to make progress but but I do
think it probably illustrates that time
completely off isn't as deleterious as a
lot of people think it will be
especially when you're talking a
one-week duration versus three I mean
three weeks off is a significant amount
of time off yeah that's a long time but
yeah like a week it's fine I think I
think lifting becomes such a large part
of people's identities that like taking
a week out of the gym completely is
almost like a threat to identity to a
lot of people and so like they want to
believe they're gonna lose all of their
games just so they can justify always
going to the gym yeah but man yeah like
and so I mean like talking to clients
they'll be like hey I'm going on
vacation I'm not sure that I'll be able
to find like a good gym near the hotel
like what should I do with my training
I'm like dude like I can write you some
workouts that you can do in your
vacation but you're on vacation like
just take time off and they're like oh I
can do that like yes you can do that
come on like you take two weeks off a
year that's that's not that's not gonna
[ __ ] you up yeah so yeah like probably
not probably not theoretically optimal
but as long as you're not taking like a
quarter of your time completely off of
training by doing a complete unload once
like one week out of every month it's
probably fine and even if you did do
that that would probably be fine as well
we've talked about we've talked about
John Cole on the podcast before I'm
sure I think we've talked about him on
here I think so
so like the way he trained is he worked
out once per week those workouts were
like 6 to 8 hours long but he just
trained essentially all day every
Saturday and not at all Sunday through
Friday so I mean one could conceptualize
that as a six-day d load
he took a week off every week he took
yeah that's what he did he took of
however many hours are in the week he
took that number of hours minus 6 off
between sessions yeah and he was fine so
yeah I mean I I don't think you need to
worry all that much about missing a week
of training every now and again yeah I
mean my approach to Delos is fairly
similar I would add one additional thing
so you talked about you know you could
do your proactive D loads that are kind
of scheduled you know into the program
day one you've also got your reactive D
loads where you're like okay this I can
sense that it's probably time I use
something that I think you could call a
prospective D load okay and what I mean
by that is I I do enjoy traveling and I
don't enjoy training while traveling
because usually my workouts even if I
try to do them they tend to suck and
they take away from time like if I'm in
London I don't necessarily want to spend
a significant portion of that in a gym
unless it's like a fitness trip where
I'm working out with fitness people then
that's like a social thing more than a
training thing but like if I'm going
somewhere to like see the sights I don't
necessarily want to spend a huge
percentage of that trip in a gym you
know I want to go see the sights yeah
for sure
and so what I'll do is I'll if I see
that I've got those travel dates in my
calendar I will program my training to
basically crescendo up into that such
that by the time I get to that trip I
really need a week off so I'll almost
like intentionally plan to overreach
leaning into that trip so you know if
you're someone who gets a little bit
stressed out about taking a week off or
you want to make sure that you know a
week off isn't necessarily optimal but
how do I make it less suboptimal
that's one thing that I've done in the
past especially when I was really
ramping up my training like now I just
don't train ever cuz I suck but but back
then that was a strategy I used that I
actually liked a lot because like it
it essentially justified taking a week
off I've also done that in the past if I
knew that I had a really crazy week
where I was like oh that week has just
deadlines all over it mm-hmm
I probably shouldn't spend eight hours
in a gym that week that's gonna be a
deal owed and then I'll work backwards
from there and kind of plan out my
training accordingly so I can tell
you're you're new to this whole back
pain game because I do exactly the same
thing but actually the complete opposite
thing instead of like ramping my
training up to the vacation I ramped it
up to about a week out from the vacation
and then like the week before I leave
for the vacation that's a taper because
you know if I have like a hard deadlift
day 48 hours before a long flight my
back's gonna be [ __ ] as soon as I land
so it's like instead of training hard
leading up to it I trained hard leading
up to it like a week prior and then I
then I taper into the flight okay
and that's clutch I I have done that
what I do is I dude if if if 17-year old
me could hop in a time capsule and come
forward ten years and listen to this
podcast be like how are you so broken
old man what is wrong with you dude
there was a time in my life I realize
seriously I regret this so much so I
jacked up my nose wrestling and I needed
no surgery to help me breathe better my
wrestling career was done it was over
I was literally just a high school
student with nothing to do nothing I did
in the day mattered at all and I had
excellent health care and I could have
gotten the surgery done and I swear to
God the reason I didn't get no surgery
when I was in high school and had
nothing to do and have incredible health
care coverage was because I didn't want
to take a week and a half off a training
oh yeah I mean same you know not not
with no surgery but I mean the the back
issues I have now I think they all
started due to a back injury as
sustained when I was like 16 yeah and I
should have taken time off and rehabbed
it better but I thought the lifting I
was doing at that point was just super
important and so I rehabbed it very
poorly yeah it's just crazy to look back
and when I was like 16 17 18 I was not
going to miss a workout yeah it just
would not happen no same to look back
and be like oh I'm that is a person that
I was it's like hard to even imagine
like 17 year old me would hate current
me so much and I also currently hate 17
year old me so it's it goes both
directions it's a two-way street
yeah I feel very very similar yeah I
have done that where I will actually
decide the D load and then arrange my
training accordingly now when I work
with clients it's a little bit tricky
because like you mentioned the
communication can be difficult you know
it's easier to feel your own fatigue
than to perceive an online clients
fatigue and so what I do is I have my
clients fill out a weekly check-in that
has questions pertaining to how is your
mood how's your energy level how's your
sleep things like that and I try to keep
an eye on those trends over time and so
even with my online clients I do make
the D loads fairly reactive but I
usually there's usually a period of time
where I'm keen to like really check in
on those like I'm extra alert because I
look at the calendar and I'll be like
theoretically we should be getting close
to a deal owed so it's kind of a mix
between proactive Andrea
activewear I can schedule out and be
like you know I think over the next
within the next four to six weeks it's
probably going to be about time but I
will use those weekly check-in
questionnaires and I'll look at their
progress in terms of training loads and
I'll use those to be like okay now it's
officially time so it is tricky with
clients but if you work with online
clients and you want to make sure that
you're maximizing the utility of those d
loads I think having a really nice
check-in process with a good detailed
questionnaire that goes beyond you know
really basic stuff trying to get a
really good feel of how they're feeling
how that fatigue might be accumulating
and essentially how fresh or house stale
they're feeling if you can put together
a good kind of weekly update to check
out those types of factors it can
probably put you in a position where
you're going to be able to like I said
really maximize the benefit of those d
loads and another thing to keep in mind
is sometimes we use a D load that is not
technically optimal from a training
perspective just because it's what we
need and what I mean by that is every
now and then the d load has less to do
with physical recovery and more to do
with just basically having a
psychologically restorative break you
know so sometimes I'll say you know what
we've been hitting it hard
you seem exhausted you seem fatigued it
doesn't seem like you very much enjoy
dragging yourself to the gym every day
at this current moment let's take a week
and just not go to the gym and is that
necessarily optimal in all cases from a
programming perspective probably not but
sometimes that's exactly what somebody
needs and you know it goes more into we
brought this question up earlier but not
how to deal ugh not when to D load but
y2d load yeah yeah and sometimes you
just need a week out of the gym and
that's totally normal now to play us out
we are going to do a little bit of a set
up for the interview we have coming for
the second half of this episode all
right so for this week's episode we've
got a treat for all the listeners we've
got a really good interview with michael
ray
and Michael is a chiropractor who has a
very he's got a really good
understanding of the pain science and
it's one of his main areas of interest
and he's really big on the
biopsychosocial model as it pertains to
pain and so he talks about a lot in our
interview I certainly don't want to
steal his thunder because he'll go into
some detail but I did want to basically
prime our listeners to have a general
understanding of what that is before we
jump into the deep end with the
interview so um when it comes to pain
[Music]
there was kind of always this like
traditional viewpoint a tissue gets
broken or damaged we experience pain you
fix the tissue pains gone and that was
kind of the old-school way of viewing
pain now especially in the fitness space
there's increased awareness of this
biopsychosocial model so do you mind
given a very very brief kind of overview
of what that adds to the picture yeah so
the the older model of pain like the
tissue damage exclusive model of pain I
guess is often referred to as the
Cartesian model named after Rene
Descartes because it assumes a mind-body
duality essentially so if you want to
just read about Descartes philosophy
that is something to do at another time
but basically you know he thought that
like your body was essentially a meat
sack in your mind was like a
transcendent quality almost and that the
two weren't all that related and so how
that relates to pain is you know some
sort of tissue is damaged in your body
your brain you know senses that as pain
something going on in your body which is
very very separate from your brain and
that's just kind of how pain worked
we're basically your mind is one thing
your body is another thing even though
your brain is in your body for some
reason they're completely separate and
entirely separated and never the twain
shall meet
the biopsychosocial model of pain
recognizes that that is not at all how
things work that
your brain is just as much in your body
as your kidneys are and therefore
basically all of this stuff is
interconnected and so tissue damage can
absolutely cause pain certainly is
something that very very heavily
influences pain if someone jabs an ice
pick through your quad that's going to
cause tissue damage it's kind of hurt
those two things are related
however tissue damages is not always
causative of pain and it is not the only
thing that contributes to the pain
experience so the biopsychosocial model
of pain essentially conceptualizes pain
almost as like an emotion that tissue
damage is is something that contributes
to it so for example if you are
depressed
like if you have clinical depression a
lot of people who are depressed are also
in a considerable amount of pain even
though they have you know no discernible
tissue damage anywhere in their body but
their psychological state very much
Prime's them to experience pain another
example is a lot of times people with
chronic pain sometimes that starts as
tissue damage like you have an injury
you have some sort of damaged tissue
that hurts
then your body repairs that but pain
still sticks around even you know in the
ongoing absence of tissue abnormalities
and then sometimes you can have tissue
damage that that doesn't coincide with
pain so for example your menisci are
that they have a pretty low density of
of nociceptors or maybe they have none I
don't think it's not but they don't have
many and so it's it's not at all
uncommon to take scans of people's knees
see that they're menisci look kind of
[ __ ] up but they don't they're not
experiencing the knee pain they don't
you know feel any deleterious effects of
that
so yeah the the tissue damage does
generally influence pain it's it's
related to pain in some way shape or
form but psychological factors and
psychosocial factors are also
contributors to the pain experience so
that that's essentially what what this
model saying and it's it is the model
that you know the field of pain science
the people who actually study the stuff
say is you know the best way we
currently have to explain the phenomenon
of pain yeah and so you know it's as you
said our experience of what pain is is
certainly influenced by psychological
factors and social factors but you know
I think it's necessary to get a little
primer of that theory obviously
Michael's going to give a really great
nuanced take on it one of the reasons I
wanted to prime the audience on that is
because sometimes people with this
concept get carried away and they say
things that might be considered kind of
dumb and what I mean by that is like any
time there's a new exciting idea there's
going to be some really smart people
that kind of nudge it along and give
really nuanced takes but there's gonna
be like some small percentage of people
who kind of misinterpret that and go a
little too far and so we certainly don't
want to give the impression that like
there is no relationship whatsoever
between tissue damage and pain all this
model indicates is that it's it's
substantially more complicated than just
a one to one relationship in which
tissue damage causes pain and the pain
you perceive is completely entirely
proportional to the degree of tissue
damage it's more complicated than that
so I don't want listeners to perceive
this as saying oh I think I messed
myself up in the gym and I'm hurt but I
heard on the podcast that pain was just
like just psychological so I'm gonna go
ahead and train through that and hurt
myself even more biopsychosocial still
has bio in it okay so don't ignore your
experience of pain but just understand
it's more complicated than that
and obviously Michaels gonna go into a
great deal of detail about what we can
actually do with
model and what it means for us as it
pertains to lifting all right so after
the music Michael is going to give us a
great nuance to take on the
biopsychosocial model of pain and what
it means for lifters it's a really
really fascinating interview and we hope
you enjoy
[Music]
all right guys we have Michael Ray on
the line how's it going Michael hey
what's up Greg oh not too much how about
you I can't complain just trying to get
started on this Tuesday it's Tuesday
right Tuesday morning a thing that feels
right so we're we're actually very
honored that you're coming on for for
all of the listeners Michael is he and
his wife are having their first kids
soon so this very well could be the last
public interview he does for the next
like 18 years ever yes so so we're we're
happy to be be here for his swan song oh
so that may have been a darker start
than was necessary but whatever we're
just gonna roll with it
it's so for for everyone who doesn't
know Michael is a master's in exercise
science
he is a doctor of chiropractic and he
currently works with barbell medicine so
and actually I'm pretty curious about
that how did you get started with with
barbell medicine what what did that look
like yeah this interesting story
I've known Austin probably the longest
Austin Meraki for maybe three years now
and then I met Jordan like two years ago
or so and so we had been like
communicating throughout this time and
Derick and I had already been running
the logic of rehab on our own for a
couple of years and we were thinking
about doing some like remote stuff and
doing other ventures and we had been
chatting with them and they were like
hey why don't you guys just come do this
with us you know we could use your help
with topics like pain and rehabilitative
services and just trying to help
athletes work through and return to
activity that are dealing with pain and
you know we enjoyed all the chats that
we had previously in the past so it
seemed like a good fit and so we came on
board with them last August and it's
been awesome since do a lot of writing
with them for for the blog as far as
like pain and Rehab related stuff
and then do remote consultations with
them so it's been a good good fit I got
no complaints very cool very cool
and your your masters and exercise
science was that was that a program with
a with a thesis or not it was yes I
suffered through it and apparently
survived what was your research on yes
it was on my Master's is an exercise
science but my concentration was motor
control and rehabilitation and so the
lab I worked in was very heavy in
neuroscience and specifically neuro
imaging so MRI and fMRI and so we did a
case control study on kids dealing with
developmental coordination disorder
which the easiest way to think about
this would be that they aren't
developing normal fine and gross motor
skills at the age appropriateness we
would expect to see and we wanted to see
if we could identify hopefully no one's
asleep just yet we she identified neural
correlates with MRI comparing them to
normally noord of normatively developing
children just wanted to see do we find
brain correlates that are different so
we did structural MRIs and we also did
fMRI where we had them do it fine motor
tasks like move a joystick and a MRI and
then compared the two to see if there
were differences and then the ultimate
goal was going to be eventually which
could have easily probably turned into a
dissertation for a PhD would have been
to do an intervention to see if we could
affect those neural correlates that's
super cool
so I I know that a non-negligible
amount of people will see doctor of
chiropractic and get a little leery
they'll be like well white why is he not
a DPT yeah but like I I know you I know
you know you're [ __ ] like that that's
why we're having you on the podcast but
for for our listeners for whom our trust
in you is not sufficient is there
anything you would just like to say
about like the DC and how you personally
practice that may help put some people's
minds a little bit more at ease yeah
absolutely
and I honestly I
you've heard me talk about this I'm sure
like I hate titles mostly because it's a
false sense of perceived authority but I
get that it's the societal thing and
that's the world we live in so they're
not gonna go away but with that said I'm
actually happy people would be skeptical
I hope that if we're doing our jobs
correctly especially what we try to do a
barbell medicine is empower people to be
inquisitive and questioning and
skeptical so I want people to question
everyone that would be my kind of like
hope in life
within reason and so for me I kind of
went through a lot of different careers
leading into what I'm currently doing I
actually didn't start my doctor until I
was 27 and so I went through out of
undergrad into law enforcement at that
for a little bit I was also a personal
training on the side because I I started
working for gems in 2003 in some
capacity and so I realized I like
personal training a lot but knew just
enough to like not really do anything
beneficial long term for people went
back for a master's yeah it was like um
maybe if I actually want to help you I
should learn a little more about this
stuff so I left law enforcement but you
know that that's a [ __ ] crazy concept
that that is that's how Eric and I are
wired as well and that's that's one of
the things that I think bothers us the
most about the rest of the fitness
industry in general like so few people
are capable of just looking at
themselves objectively and and realizing
like well [ __ ] like I'm a dumbass like I
need to I learn more things so I can do
my job well so it's it's very refreshing
to to bump into other people who are who
are wired the same way oh yeah and I
still like think I'm a dumbass which
probably helps perpetuate this idea of
like oh I know nothing and I need to
keep reading but so I did that to the
masters I was highly contemplating a PhD
but I was kind of ready to just get out
and work and so I went into cardiology
as an exercise physiologist and did like
pacemaker and ICD and Terry
Asians and Holter monitors and EKGs and
all that fun stuff and I realized why I
was in cardiology that health from a
standpoint of modifiable risk factors
wasn't a driving conversation that was
happening where I was at and we were in
a large cardiology practice we had six
cardiologists on staff and multiple eps
and nurses and so on and so forth
and I remember vividly like having a
conversation with one of the one of the
clinicians I was like hey I noticed like
there's this 25 year old year with
hypertension and hypercholesterolemia
and we didn't really discuss like
modifiable health risk factors and their
response and you know I get it like
after in the field for a while we can
easily become jaded that happens to
anyone but they were basically like yeah
it's not really worth having those
discussions it I did it over and over
and over again it goes nowhere
and people just want a pill and that was
kind of a point in my mind where I was
like this might have either a path for
me and I think things should be done
differently and so I got out of that and
briefly did a research associate
physician at the University of South
Carolina on a track study which was
looking at physical activity and middle
schoolers and then I realized like there
is a way that I could go get a degree
that gives me freedom which turns out to
be the doctorate of chiropractic it
gives you in the United States and all
50 states physician level status which
means I can do things like evaluation
and management codes so from like a
billing perspective if you install a pcp
a primary care physician we're using the
same codes which means I have direct
access and so that large freedom made me
realize like I could go this route get
the piece of paper and then get out and
practice how I wanted to now throughout
life like I bought into a lot of silly
[ __ ] as I call it
I wince all chiropractors I had joint
manipulations done and I had grasped and
I had all kinds of stuff Johnny dealing
with really wasn't popular just yet when
I was into that stuff and when I got
into my doctorate I started questioning
things and realizing like oh this is
contextual effects and this is the
placebo effect and oh this is why I felt
like I was getting positive benefit out
of this ad nothing to do with the
narrative I was being given and
everything to do with
powers perceiving what was happening to
me and what my expectations were from
that treatment and at that point it was
a kind of a switch for me where I really
started becoming skeptical with clinical
practice and then I was very fortunate
to meet people that are still to the
statement towards to me like Derrick
which Greg you know Derrick is well one
of my best friends and in meeting him
and then meeting people in the clinical
athlete Network getting questioned by
other clinicians like why do you believe
that I was like oh [ __ ] I'm yet again in
a situation where I don't know answers
to stuff let me go find these things out
and that's kind of what's led me down
this rabbit hole of like what is pain
and how should it be treating it and
what are the narratives we have support
to say to people that's probably way
sorry if I was a diatribe like way off
no no Michael I did have a question
about that you mentioned during your
schooling that was the time where you
started saying you know looking in the
mirror and saying well why did I believe
this worked he started becoming more
skeptical was that from the training you
received in your formal schooling or was
that kind of a self-motivated desire to
figure out more of the the granular
detail of not just the end effect but
how and why these things are are so
common
I definitely think some of that thought
process was instilled in schooling but I
also think it took me kind of being avid
about trying to figure these things out
like a willingness and desire to look at
these things and say maybe I'm wrong
about a lot of stuff I thought about
with clinical practice and and maybe
actually question this stuff a lot more
and try to find supportive evidence for
how we approach things and chiropractic
school like is very much based off of
now for a lot of schools it's moving
more towards let's be
neuromusculoskeletal rehabilitative
clinicians and farther away from like
very dogmatic non-supported ideas and I
don't even give it the label of theory
as some clinicians try to do for
subluxations and so that's a positive
step in the right direction for the
field but it would be very easy if I
didn't have that mindset to go to the
schooling that I went through at a very
old-school philosophy type chiropractic
school and think
every patient that came to see me which
just has subluxation like a bony
misalignment that I need to fix and ipso
facto I solve cancer or whatever else
with them which are unfortunate and
there does it go on in the field yeah
and and honestly it's a shame that the
fields getting away from that because
there's times that I want someone to
just be able to pop my elbow in in a
particular way to cure my tuberculosis
by letting my energy and there's there
is not that many people who who have
that art anymore
I don't Gwyneth Paltrow might be able to
help you she she runs group right I
think they have stuff for that yeah yeah
I was gonna say that my main gripe that
I have with the field of chiropractic
work is that while there are some very
very good ones whenever I go and give a
talk about supplements
there are supplement questions that I
simply don't even know where to begin
the answer and I think a lot of those
originated from like some rogue
chiropractor like I mean dude every time
I give a supplement talk it's like a
thing I've never heard about and it's
like did you know that it actually cures
cancer but all the pharmaceutical
companies are you know burying all the
evidence and it's like jeez I don't know
where to start man my my favorite one
that that got like kind of popular
recently for that like quote unquote
natural cancer cures is ground-up
apricot pits and look and the reason and
the reason that's incredible is apricot
pits have non-negligible levels of
cyanide in them and so like consuming a
bunch of cyanide pits will make sure you
don't die of cancer because you died of
cyanide poisoning first it won't matter
right so that's the art is you gotta
flirt with that you know you need to
kill most the cells of your body but not
all of them right you try to get as
close as you can with those toxins Gregg
then you forget all about it that that's
that's the kind of outside the box
thinking that that big pharma doesn't
doesn't want you to do like you know
they could
be able to study a drug that's you know
60% effective at eradicating this cancer
but if you can take a natural remedy
that is a hundred percent effective at
killing cancer cells because it kills
all of your cells I feel like the
radiation that's just another approach
to treating things that I feel like
people's minds aren't unlocked enough
and unleashed enough to really
conceptualize yet open your third eye
right that's now I would like to in the
interest of fairness take a look in the
mirror and admit that there are plenty
of people with my schooling who say
remarkably stupid things so we're not
picking on on that field but I have
gotten some very creative supplement
questions from that area it's it's
interesting like I try as hard as I can
to zoom out big picture as often as I
can and I think one of the biggest
issues with the chiropractic field it's
a curse and a blessing is I do have
direct access which means like day one
graduation pass your licensure and
suddenly you have this power to go out
open your own business with that comes
this idea that oh I've got to keep my
lights on I've got to put food on my
table for my family I've gotta do XYZ
I'm not saying this is because we could
certainly turn this into an ethical
debate but it drives people to look for
things to profit off of and I think
because of that they start seeking out
alternatives of things they can sell to
their patients because clinical practice
is so complex and so complicated to talk
about pain with people that they're like
well I can just sign up with standard
process which is a major company within
the chiropractic profession for
supplements and they can just tell me
how to sell this and now I've got
another way to profit off of and I don't
think that's right at all but I think
that's probably what's happening I I
think that's a I think that's a good
jumping-off point into what we actually
wanted to talk about today so one of one
of the reasons we we wanted to have you
on is to discuss pain because I think
that that's
I mean pain is a concept that all of us
have experience with but I think it's
something that is at least somewhat well
understood in the research but the like
academic understanding of pain and what
it is and what research tells us it is
and how it operates is very very
different from the way most people and
especially most athletes and coaches
think about and conceptualize pain so I
guess just to lead us off what is pain
and what are some like major
misconceptions that most of our
listeners probably have about it oh I
need some alcohol
I will do my best to define what is pain
although I will say it's it's almost
noon if you are drinking on our show
we're not gonna throw stones
unfortunately having my clinic hit I
have patients later so I have that baby
frowned upon but um yeah I think what is
pain is the ultimate question that not
only clinicians and today are trying to
answer but philosophers for an extremely
long time I've been trying to answer and
discuss and I used to teach a seminar
specifically on this stuff so we taught
scientific principles of sports rehab
over a weekend and one of the main talks
was on pain and I would actually open up
with a DMX song that was rapping
Nietzsche basically saying like you know
pain is a part of life and you have to
find meaning and you're suffering and I
think that has a lot of applicability
not to be like too negative into this
podcast but when we're looking at
defining pain right now the best we have
to give the field a collective
definition would have been the
International Association for the study
of pain definition which came out in the
1970s and that was the initial step in
the community from an academic
standpoint to unify the field to give a
taxonomy to discuss the topic and their
definition has a lot to be desired
but it was the first time where we saw
them say that you could have actual or
potential tissue damage during the
experience of pain so we know socially
most of us grow up believing and me
included that pain equals bad equals
tissue damage equals avoid and that says
this is kind of an innate biological
adaptation both from an evolutionary
standpoint but as well as from a social
learning standpoint and sometimes that
works sometimes it is applicable that
something negative is happening to me
and maybe I'm having tissue damage to
get into a little bit of the
neuroscience of it this would be if you
had nociception which is when the body
has thermo mechanical or chemical tissue
damage then the nosey suckers get
activated and it sends up information
peripherally to the brain right and then
at that point the brain kind of has to
make sense of what's happening and the
easy part of this in the biomedical part
of this and what's been going on for
thousands of years at this time about
how we've been looking at this stuff is
you have tissue damage that's correlated
to your pain most clinicians say
causative of your pain and if I can come
in and just fix this tissue damage it's
a fact oh I fix you and I correct the
problem
and this is prevalent today I'm if I
were to make bets I would be bit willing
to bet a lot of money regardless of the
clinicians title whether it's MD DoD CPT
whoever if you go for a consultation
this is how the patients gonna be framed
that they're presenting with the symptom
and there's some underlying
pathophysiological or pathol anatomical
cause that needs to be fixed the problem
with this is what we're realizing now
since the 70s is there's another way to
view clinical practice and so George
Engle came out in the 1970s as well at
the same time the International
Association for study of pain was formed
and said hey you know we're looking at
this a little bit incorrectly that yes
at times you could have tissue damage
that's associated with pain but
regardless of the level of biological
involvement we're dealing with human
beings and we need to also consider the
psychological and sociological
correlates of the painful experience and
so
as we slowly dived into that more and
more and I've done more research on the
topic we realized that pain especially
as it persists is a very poor correlate
to tissue damage meaning you could
present to my office with a complaint of
acute low back pain and it has very
little to anything to do with actual
some identifiable tissue problem and in
fact this is what the research is
showing us that if I were to try to do a
scan on your spine nine times out of ten
especially based off of your age I'm
probably gonna find some quote-unquote
abnormality and it's become so prevalent
that we're now moving away from
abnormalities because it sets the wrong
expectation and we're saying things like
normative aging adaptation and so we
realized that you could a have a
subjective experience of pain that may
or may not be related to tissue damage
but then be that's a highly
individualistic experience that may be
or is related to your past experiences
what you think pain actually means and
then your learned responses to dealing
with it I'll stop there because I don't
want to go I don't want to go too far
down into the rabbit hole so so what
you're getting at is essentially there
are plenty of people who have imaging
results that would look pathological
that don't experience pain and plenty of
people with you know a lot of pain who
if you look at their scans are pretty
unremarkable is what you're what you're
saying basically yeah it's it's it's
super individualistic there's a study
that I like to talk about when I give
lectures on this that looks at the
mosaic of pain and they basically took
three hundred and twenty-one individuals
and applied an external heat stimulus
and then had them rate their pain now if
pain were a universal experience that
wasn't highly individualistic I would
expect it to see a horizontal line
everyone rated the stimulus the same
because it's the same stimulus what ends
up happening is you have 321 different
reporting of how they experience pain
and how they rated it and so we know
because of that in other studies like
that that this is highly individualistic
and severity and intensity are
individualistic and severity and
intensity actually don't correlate to
anything meaningful from a biological
tissue issue to your point Eric if you
present it
it's my clinic with the cute low back
pain let's say hey I wouldn't image you
because that's what the guidelines are
telling us there's very very few cases
we should image for the for that
experience
but be if I did have that imaging on
hand you could have textbook imaging and
tell me you're in a ten out of ten out
of paint but then I could look at
someone else who has what we would
classify as severe degenerative disc
disease which is shitty language and I
highly don't recommend people use that
language but if I did that and you're
like I feel great I don't have any
issues you know there's no problem so
being able to figure out like the
individuals experience is pretty much
the game of clinical practice yeah so I
don't want to jump right to the
conclusion if you were planning to carry
this on for another hour but my question
would be if you have these people coming
in with pain and in many cases pain is
dissociated from structural damage what
the hell do you do for their pain if
there's not structural damage to fix
yeah that's kind of what we're all
fighting about
um and the unfortunate part of this is
what can happen with schooling is you do
get indoctrinated and that forms your
frame about how you look at clinical
practice and it's something we try to
fight against strongly is especially a
barbell medicine but it would be easy
for me as a chiropractor to see someone
presenting with pain the problem is a
subluxation or a leg length discrepancy
or pelvic torsion or and I just need to
fix that for them and then if I were an
MD I could look at it from another lens
and then I just need to give them a
medication or from an orthopedic surgeon
and I'm viewing them and they're imaging
that I just need to do surgery or some
type of other more intensive
intervention if I'm a massage therapist
then I just need to mock massage you
know quote-unquote tight muscles or
strengthen loose muscles from a coaching
standpoint like the list goes on that
how we're framing the problem is how we
think we should solve it and it turns
out we have a lot more evidence of what
we shouldn't be doing and what we
shouldn't be saying versus what we
should be doing and what we should be
saying and so when the patient presents
to our office with pain we've got to
figure out what's their experience with
it and then from a clinical standpoint
is there something that's going to
negatively alter prognosis like old
likely clinical outcomes for this case
if I don't intervene and so if it's not
gonna alter case management then that
makes it a very different discussion
about how to move forward
I think I'm somewhat answered your
questionnaire yeah so my my general
question kind of about about this whole
area is that so I I think I think it's
very clear that there's not like a
one-to-one correlation between pain and
tissue damage you can be in ton of pain
with very little or no tissue damage and
you have a lot of tissue damage with no
pain but something that that I that I
haven't seen address that I'm like
genuinely curious about is like what
what is what's the correlation between
the two things and I and by that I'm not
asking for like a specific r-value but
like the the idea that the pain and
tissue damage are the same thing I would
I would assume has to at least come from
a common experience that they are at
minimum related so like kind of how how
common are those cases where you know
someone has a ton of pain but no tissue
damage or a ton of tissue damage and no
pain like does pain and damage in
general scale with like just some weird
outliers or just kind of more generally
what is the strength of that
relationship they're very poor
unfortunately I wish it weren't the case
because it would be so much easier that
if you came in and I could highly
correlate the two then I know how to fix
this issue the immediate outside of this
is a false premise though it's this idea
that the biology and the pain experience
or are highly related and like but
that's what George angle was trying to
demonstrate with the biopsychosocial
model is that the person's thoughts and
beliefs and their social kind of
grooming so to speak and how they grew
up in the environment influence it so
much that it muddies the waters a lot
and so we have people like Laura Mosely
who's written on this who's a researcher
out of Australia and talks about that
there isn't a strong correlation and
then most especially as pain persists
and so the usual talk is well if I shot
you
you're probably gonna experience pain
maybe it really depends on context
because pain is a goal-directed
attentional focus action and so meaning
like if I experience pain the whole
point is as draw a somatic awareness to
a body region and then I want to protect
it if I have a goal that outweighs my
experience currently with pain then I
can just mute it and soldiers in battle
is a great example the ability for
someone to experience massive tissue
damage but with a goal-directed action
that's far outweighing what they're
experiencing and so they can continue on
until they complete the goal and then
afterwards it's like oh I have this
massive trauma to my system
and there's tons of examples of this
that people have posed like published
case reports on with this stuff
happening do I think that acute tissue
trauma is more highly correlated with
nociception which may more likely have
the person experience pain yes but do I
think that that could also not be the
case yes and is there a way that I can
apply an algorithm to figure it out it's
too highly individualistic that it's not
possible you know the the way you just
explained that reminded me a lot of like
the like the does hypertrophy contribute
to strength gains god I hate to even
call it a debate but the the debate
that's that's ongoing because like the
the unsophisticated approach to that is
like yeah like if you get bigger you're
gonna get stronger and then there's some
people who will go like the complete
opposite route and say like oh these two
things are completely unrelated but what
it sounds like is you're saying tissue
damage related to nociception
nociception related to pain but there's
a lot of other inputs in the system so
you can't just draw a direct line
between the two which is kind of
similar to the the relationship between
hypertrophy and strength gains like I
purchase probably contribute to strength
gains but you can't just draw a line
between the two and assume that they're
going to be like super tightly related
in in all or even most circumstances
yeah yeah and I'm somewhat familiar with
I've been following you guys's public
discussions on that stuff but I think
that's a great example like it is it's
so individualistic that it's difficult
to say the level of tissue damage that's
involved of things and so I don't even
try to silo it out because I think that
that would still be a dichotomous
approach in a biomedical approach so
like I don't think I've mentioned
anything on this but biomedicine is
basically based on duality right mind
versus body and you can trace this all
the way back to the cart and the
original I was going to say [ __ ]
Descartes did it did did he ever like
actually write anything about that or
did people just like take his mind-body
dualism and apply it to this stuff and
call it a Cartesian model so I don't
know I just want to know like how much
the hatred of blame because he was yeah
but like how big of a piece of [ __ ] was
he so I don't want to just blame him and
I do think that he gets a lot of the
blame but when I started looking into
this it turns out there's a lot of
things that were going on a at the time
the church was the reigning Supreme
Being of the land and the church was
basically like hey you guys can do you
know you anatomist and you classical
science people like Galileo you guys can
do whatever you want with the body if
you guys want to go do two dissections
that's fine I don't even care if you
dissect the brain but when it comes to
thoughts beliefs and behaviors we use
the church on that and so instantly you
had this separation and divide of don't
enter into the don't bring the two
realms together
this isn't your gonna study the mind
we're gonna study that but you can study
the body and so now we automatically
have this kind of cars madea's machine
this mind versus body approach and you
see the birth of biomedicine where we're
now technicians and our job is to just
find a problem and fix it and what's
happening in the research is we're
getting [ __ ] and we're realizing
things that we've been calling
problems we don't have data to support
to say are actually problems and they're
just normative humanistic adaptations
that occur either evolutionarily
speaking or through adaptations through
life which the adaptations through life
is where a lot of people are saying hey
maybe we shouldn't call that spot of
genitive dis disease or we shouldn't
worry about acromion shape at all or we
shouldn't worry about rotator cuff tears
and a lot of different contexts and so
that's where it gets really really
tricky so I think that was a good segue
actually because you you said you wanted
to discuss joint morphology when you
came on so so you mentioned you
mentioned acromion x' and and that was
one of the other things he brought up
when we were when we were chatting
before we started recording so as I
understand it you heard our first Q&A
episode and I believe either Eric and I
or maybe just me made some statements
about I honestly don't even remember
what but I think it was related to join
morphology and injury risk so like what
does the research say about that and how
did I [ __ ] it up well we all I believe I
did as well so we were both in trouble
Greg wednesdaya double and we all we all
[ __ ] things up and I [ __ ] things up
all the times they relates to pain but I
mean that's that's why we're having
y'all now like I don't what one of the
reasons why to this point I've like
pretty much exclusively communicated
with the internet by writing articles
and why starting a podcast was a little
bit scary to me is like I know that I
don't know a lot of stuff and that a lot
of the things I think are probably wrong
and one of the things I can do in an
article is like fact check the [ __ ] out
of myself whereas like hop on a podcast
and it's like you know two or three guys
shooting the [ __ ] they're very well
maybe things that come out of my mouth
that
completely wrong because there's no way
I can fact check myself in real time and
it's not like we can keep all topics of
conversation within the tiny little silo
of things that I know really really well
so one of one of the things that I I'm
glad that she reached out because like
on one hand I could see someone probably
justifiably so just like going in some
forum and like tearing me a new [ __ ]
and being like ah this guy's a complete
dumbass like look at what he was saying
or like you know someone very well could
have just said nothing to me and let it
stand so I'm I'm glad that she reached
out and said like hey let's talk about
this stuff so then we could bring you on
the show to to correct the record but
not in a like super antagonistic way
yeah and this is one of those great
examples where like you know we have a
partnership on the podcast so when you
say a bunch of stupid [ __ ] about
pineapple on pizza I catch up and I can
help direct your course a little bit
that's all by the way yeah so if I
already dealt with that don't worry
Michael but but there are some cases
where we might both be going in the
wrong direction and hell yeah we
encourage people to say hey let me come
on and teach you something well I
definitely appreciate you guys having me
on and and the way you guys received it
was much appreciated the last thing I
want to do to two people is be this
confrontational ass I already know my
resting state is probably being an
[ __ ]
also I try to temper it especially I've
known Greg for a number of years now so
I think from like because I got off
track there with joint morphology so we
were going right yes we so usually like
people want to talk about morphological
changes on imaging and there's a couple
of ways we could frame this discussion
but let's start with like the shoulder
the interesting thing when we look at
the shoulder is like we can see
morphological changes at a very young
age and adolescent athletes and in
asymptomatic so I wrote an article on
internal impingement in the overhead
we eat for the for the shoulder and as I
was going through the research
literature I quickly realized like oh
we're seeing changes very early on now
one person could look at that and say
that's a maladaptive occurrence and
that's gonna lead to symptoms and that's
gonna be a negative long-term outcome
for them another person can look at that
and say oh their body's adapting to the
sport demands that's being placed on
their body and that's more why I tend to
reside and that's kind of where the
evidence is leading us because when we
look at prognostic factors as far as it
relates to imaging we don't have a lot
of ground to stand on especially in like
that cohort it turns out very little
ends up being related to symptoms down
the road and we can see these
adaptations throughout life even into
like MLB players and then even
afterwards so it does out it's very
difficult to look at imaging and see
acromion shape whether it's like type 1
type 2 or type 3 or subacromial spacing
in relation to the supraspinatus tendon
and it becomes even harder to say things
like you have a rotator cuff tear
because you have an acromion shaped
process that's type 3 and you have loss
of some acromial space and it's just
grinding that tissue down but what it
turns out is if you do say those things
you have a negative net effect on the
patient's beliefs and their willingness
to go engage and movement activity later
in life where this gets really
interesting is so this whole all kind of
hyper focus on this for a second this
whole idea as far as some of Criminology
compressions came from an orthopedic
physician named NIR in the 70s and NIR
basically did a non randomized study on
like 50 some-odd at individuals and it
was like yeah we're just gonna go in and
decompress this area that that makes
sense to me let's do that and then he
had some weird follow-up of like
anywhere from eight months to five years
depending on the participant and a lot
of there's a lot of red flags that I
kind of really bash the [ __ ] out of out
of this article and the shoulder
write-up I did but like during the time
it was totally normal to run randomized
control trials during this time here
that wasn't abnormal but they didn't do
it and he does a study and he gets
quoted like somewhat successful outcomes
I'm like forty people or so and that's
it we're off to the
subacromial decompression becomes the
main state treatment for what we were
classifying his impingement based
syndrome and it took 40 years before we
did randomized control trials well
conducted once and in 2017 and in 2018
we got to come out and both of them
concluded that doing sham arthroscopy
was no better than actually going in and
decompressing the joint meaning if I
willed up half the court into the
surgical room and I went in and I did a
clavicular resection and I'd decompress
the joint and whatever else that I could
we'll another person in and just make an
incision but not do anything to the
shoulder and we have up to like two-year
outcomes exactly the same same present
pain resolution same functioning and so
now we're realizing like oh maybe it
doesn't have a lot to do with what's
happening at the joint level and maybe
it has a lot more to do with other
factors outside of just what we're
seeing on imaging but we're trying to
undo four years of thinking at this
point I was gonna say yeah that line of
thinking that Greg and I were going down
is you know we didn't just make it up I
mean it's it's heavily entrenched you
know if you if you open a kind of
introductory level textbooks that
pertain to athletic training or injury
management I mean you see the stuff
right there in black and white you know
yeah yeah like when we do go outside of
like our specific areas of expertise on
this podcast talking about stuff it's
generally because or at least in my case
it's because like I'm saying something
that at least I I think or assume is
very well supported cuz yeah as far as
like the acromion goes like I learned
that in a class in college which I
assumed wasn't just completely foolish
which I realized may have been an
incorrect assumption I taught that in a
college classroom so I'm part of the
problem it's well you guys aren't alone
like this is when we were talking about
titles earlier this is pervasive
throughout all of elk health care like
the social learning aspect about what is
pain is massive and I often joke when I
talk about this is I wish
I had to the neuralyzer from men and
black where I could just like flash
maybe like I look dude this is that is
actually what paint is like forget all
this other [ __ ] and let's talk about
what it is because we keep approaching a
very complex problem from a very
reductionist standpoint and now we're
getting data and this isn't just the
shoulder I read a piece on the meniscus
where Minnesota Me's are going the same
exact way where we're having randomized
control trials coming out saying you
could pretend to do the surgery and get
the same exact outcomes of actually
doing the surgery and so we're getting
to this weird point where we're like
alright all of our thinking on the topic
of pain at least the majority of it is
probably been incorrect now what should
we be doing and so it's this weird
transition of how do we place a belief
system we're realizing it's false but
doing it in a timely manner where we
give people pragmatic application for
practice so yeah I'm I'm glad you
brought up sham arthroscopy because I
think that was I think one of the first
things that made me realize that that my
understanding of pain was too simplistic
and probably wrong is like stumbling
upon a facebook discussion that I
believe like Jonathan fasts and Lars Ave
Murray we're in like back in the day and
they shared a study looking at at the
meniscus like you brought up where
people who had a sham surgery had like
similar or like the same outcomes as
people who did actually have meniscus
surgery which like one blew me away
because like prior to that I felt that
like Oh a meniscus injury is like a
pretty serious injury that you probably
need surgery for and then - I knew that
the placebo effect was a thing but like
I kind of thought that placebos that you
were allowed to give in research were
like pills or like maybe a fake
injection I arose you could just do a
fake surgery on Peter that that's stuck
in my head mostly because of just like
the premise of the experimental setup
was was wild to me it
impressive yeah it's impressive because
some of those if you read through it the
surgeon doesn't even know what they're
doing until they're in it and then the
patient's already like unnecessary get
an envelope and they're like they were
going like okay I'm actually doing the
surgery on you so it's amazing like the
steps that some of those protocols took
to actually to look at this stuff one of
the things you mentioned was that one of
the challenges now with our our new
understanding of pain is being able to
apply that to practice and I think that
probably means one thing for pts or
chiropractors like people in your
position versus people who are coaches
or maybe they don't coach anything but
like you know they're an athlete that
they will occasionally deal with pain
and and those are the majority of the
people listening to this podcast like
either coaches or athletes not that many
pts or or Kairos so for for the
listeners like assuming you're talking
primarily to you know lifters or coaches
how how can we apply this information
and actually make it relevant like
either our own training or how we go
about talking about these issues with
with training clients or you know you
see what I'm getting that yeah I mean
this is something like we all try to
figure out on a regular basis is I
because my thing is we could easily make
this unique way up in the clouds type
discussion but we need pragmatic
application for this stuff like we're
dealing with humans and I don't need to
have nor it is time typically allocate
you know three-hour discussion on the
meaning of pain with someone and most of
the time a lot of people either may not
even care or they just want to figure
out what do I have to do to get through
this ordeal with it so if we talk about
it before someone experiences pain from
an educational standpoint I think that's
a great place to begin with people just
getting that first point down that pain
doesn't equal bad doesn't equal to
damage in all situations and regardless
of whether you've had something acutely
occur the first role of this entire
don't panic because regardless of what's
happening at the tissue level your
emotional status is directly going to
influence the severity and intensity of
your symptoms and a lot of times what
you'll see with this stuff is people can
catastrophize a situation so they can
kind of unnecessarily worry themselves
they can magnify it and then they can
feel helpless in it which is an
unfortunate part of pain is it removes
your autonomy it makes you feel like
you're not in control of the situation
and so that's kind of where we typically
begin is like educating as well as we
can meeting them where they're at about
what they think pain is and then trying
to reframe it and then from a training
standpoint realizing like just because
you do experience symptoms and training
that doesn't mean anything immediately
needs to be changed or altered or you
have to rush off to a healthcare
professional or anything like that now
this is broad generalization there's
it's going to be difficult to give
concrete guidelines for all situations
but usually what I tell will tell
athletes that I work with they
experience pain while training it's just
to say you know hey let's try another
set maybe even at that same weight and
see how you respond to it
maybe it was nothing to worry about and
it goes away and then we just continue
on with life now if you load it up with
the same weight in the same set in the
same reps and it feels worse probably
need to make an alteration and this is
where we come in and really like rate of
perceived exertion or reps on reserve
because we can say easy things like hey
just drop that or key down by a point
and that gives you some control over the
situation which instantly makes you feel
like you have some autonomy and it kind
of minimizes that that fear and panic of
what are these symptoms mean and so we
talk about this from kind of a couple
step process the first is educating the
second would be load management and
however we can accomplish that and then
the third would be if we've managed load
appropriately like we've adjusted our PE
we've adjusted volume and frequency and
symptoms still aren't improving then the
next step could be that we alter
exercise selection so maybe we just take
that exercise out for a little bit of
time and then reintroduce it and then
the last would be finally for you're not
still good not getting resolution with
that stuff then probably need to have a
little more involved discussion about
what's going on and maybe
consultation but those are general
guidelines we give athletes that are
dealing with symptoms how to work
through it and do so in a controlled
manner where they're not panicking and
they feel like they have some self
efficacy with the process I really like
that and I've kind of been working
myself through that not with a client
but with with me I've been having a
tremendous amount of hip pain and you
know I tried to go the the traditional
route of like you know we'll get some
imaging done and you know kind of did
the whole clinical run around with all
the different specialists and whatnot
and I realized you know I kind of want
to manage this more like the way you
just described messed around with how I
loaded it the types of exercises I was
doing and it's not perfect yet but it's
still at a at a really manageable spot
you know I there's certain exercises I
know if I do them it's gonna cause me
pain I know if I stay away from them I'm
probably not going to have pain which is
a way better place than I used to be
yeah but because it is hip it does bring
me to the last thing that I really
wanted to get your feedback on I know we
talked a little bit about shoulder
morphology as it pertains to pain and
injury Greg and I on a previous podcast
also had a question about squat depth in
which we talked a little bit about hip
morphology so did you have anything to
share as it pertains to the the
morphology of hip and how it affects the
way that we squat and train yeah and so
I think there's a couple of things we
could talk about with this the first
would be it's not it's not a good line
of thinking to think that movement
should be avoided for anyone because
what can this can do is kind of feed
into kinesio phobia which is gonna be
fewer affordance of movement and that's
that's not a good place to be and that's
actually one of the major core let's we
see with persistent pain based symptoms
if someone thinks pain equals bad equals
harm equals avoid don't do something
which then removes their autonomy it can
actually for an athlete sacrificer
identity which makes him feel a lot
worse and then it feeds into this this
model called fear avoidance behavior
model which means kind of what you were
saying with with
your hip is I know if I go do this
movement I'm gonna get symptoms so we
create this self-fulfilling prophecy
based off of prior experiences and that
can perpetuate avoidance so one of the
first things clinically we do is get you
doing the things you don't want to do
but in a less threatening manner and it
turns out since pain doesn't correlate
well to tissue damage for a lot of
scenarios that means if you are
experiencing symptoms it gives you a
chance to challenge that threat and
overcome it and that overcoming it part
is a win under your belt which gives you
confidence in the ability to do
something which helps reframe what is
pain and how best to respond to it as it
relates to joint morphology we don't
have any evidence that you shouldn't do
something because the way a joint looks
and it's also highly unlikely we would
ever advocate for a pre-emptive
screening for this kind of stuff like it
just wouldn't make sense an easy example
of this would be tenon op at these we
know you can have a dieter and it a
tendon and have no symptoms whatsoever
and the risk for future rupture and say
like the Achilles is extremely low like
3 to 4 percent not enough for us to go
around scanning people so that's that's
something that isn't likely to happen
and it would take substantial evidence
to change that now we've talked a little
bit about how perception or kind of
anticipated pain responses might play
into some of these factors yeah now I
know for me personally I don't want to
make this like a show about me but my
hip pain tends to wake me at night yeah
so like at a time where I mean I don't
understand pain or the brain nearly as
well as you but I would think that
that's a time when I be not particularly
likely to kind of think a pain into
existence and am i off on that no and
like it'll be the type of thing where I
wake up with very intense pain that
maybe once or twice I might have shouted
I totally get it
and so here's a couple of things on this
one like people typically take away from
these conversations like oh it's all in
my head and I'm like no it's all of you
you are your mind you are your body and
it takes both to have a pain experience
in fact it really takes a third
component which is your environment
because it's context related
often times reporting like when I go to
squats when I notice my symptoms and so
like a near situation it's it's almost
as if the biopsychosocial model involves
bio psycho and social yes it's crazy how
that works out so yeah it is nuanced and
with all of that in mind like in regards
to your situation
what I usually tell people is here's the
thing once you become census sensitized
which just means you're symptomatic in
an area that does two things typically
especially as symptoms persist I mean we
don't have to get into this but it can
be called like central and peripheral
sensitization type stuff but you have a
tissue tolerance level for what an area
is willing to undergo without this kind
of feeding into symptomatic development
and you have a threshold for activation
to the area when symptoms tend to
persist the threshold is lowered and
your tolerance is lowered so it's kind
of double whammy where it doesn't take a
lot to set you off and you can't
tolerate a lot to the area and so once
we were into this sensitized state
people do report like I was just asleep
in bed and maybe you rolled over onto it
or whatever and I got extreme symptoms
out of it and there's a couple of
talking points there being like yes that
sucks and I get that but to set
expectations that is part of the process
and it's nothing to get panicky about
are worried about the meaning of the
symptoms and the good news is this is
going to get better and as we work
through this process those symptoms are
going to repress and you're going to
notice them less and less and the good
news is you're going to start doing the
things that you want to be able to do
that you feel like you can't which is
gonna further help with bringing up your
threshold and your tolerance levels but
I talked about that from you Eric as an
individual not your hips tissued level
and tolerance level and threshold level
does that make sense yeah and so then
this sensitization is happening at like
the the neurobiology level basically it
can yeah yeah and so it's just trying to
like work through that thought process
but the biggest thing as well from a
clinical standpoint is we need to be
empathetic and so like empathy would
mean like I'm not giving you a label
that's stigmatizing you so I
scan you're happy but like yeah you have
femoral acetabular impingement it's a
cam this is what's going on this is what
we're gonna do to fix it and then that
fails which FAI surgical intervention
has [ __ ] outcomes continuously in the
research but because I gave you a
biomechanical narrative that this is a
joint morphological issue or a labral
tear issue
I'm hinged to that and now every
subsequent intervention that I utilize
to kind of quote unquote fix you has to
be involving that joint but if I
approach it from a humanistic or
holistic you know not holistic from the
alternative medicine world holistic is
you as a human being and what you're
experiencing and talk about like yes I
understand that you're having hip
symptoms but what matters here is how we
deal with this and how we give you back
control and how we move you closer
towards your goals and now I frame this
much differently for my hip problem but
to a problem that this person named Erik
in front of me is dealing with and help
us can I help them through this process
that different approach is massive in
the clinical world awesome I mean yeah
then if that means I don't have to get
hip surgery then that's a very suitable
answer to me yeah so it's it gets tricky
because then the question is like the
the big thing meniscus surgery research
is going through is like okay like
clinical practice guidelines are now
saying we should not be doing then
discectomies meniscal repairs and
adolescence has [ __ ] support for it at
all like that surgery is readily being
done in youth athletics and we have
almost no evidence to support that
approach whatsoever and so now the
question becomes is there a sub cohort
that would benefit from this
intervention and with the meniscus we're
realizing no study actually just came
out this year that at this time it
doesn't appear that anyone should be
undergoing that surgery then that
pertains to both meniscus removal and
repair yeah yeah the meniscal repair
research is almost none very very little
to demonstrate that we should be doing
that and then minitek Tamizh and
complete contradiction to it and so then
the the the idea would be that you just
continue living with a torn meniscus
without any surgical
invention whatsoever yeah and that's the
the difficult part is if I framed the
knee the person presenting to my clinic
with knee symptoms as having a meniscus
issue I've given you a problem to fix
and that's really difficult to unring
that Bell
so sometimes knowing isn't better
interesting we've kept you here for an
hour at this point is is there anything
on on these sorts of topics that hasn't
come up yet
but that you see a lot of people either
discussing or getting wrong that that
you think our listeners should be
exposed to the correct information on I
would say we've already touched on a lot
of it pain definition and it not being
well correlated to tissue damage and
then how to manage things pragmatically
and a training setting for athletes and
then from that realizing like we don't
have evidence to say you can't do
something at all like that those
narratives aren't true and I what I
typically see in the fitness community
that just like instantly spikes my BP
like 20 points is like a oh you have
pain perception that's really bad you're
gonna hurt yourself and then also the
technique discussion which is extremely
prevalent of well if you do a movement
that way you know like snap city you're
gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ] up don't do that
and it turns out we actually have even
less evidence for that type of dichotomy
approach to movement it's good versus
bad as well and then this becomes very
tricky for people because they're like
what am I even doing as a coach like you
here for me to teach you how to do a
movement and how to do it appropriately
and you can still teach movement to
people there's nothing wrong with that
but it turns out that movement is
arbitrary based on the end goal and
there's a lot of different ways to get
to the end goal and you don't have to
confine people to this one way to squat
or this one way to deadlift or this one
way to do something that we can have
movement expression and still get to the
outcome and you can give broad
generalizations about how to complete
the movement because it's it's task
specific so we know there may be a
biomechanically advantageous way to do
it to pretend prove outcomes and
performance but when we try to attach
those narratives to
well this is why you're having pain
because your lumbar spine flexed in the
bottom of a squad's yet like a quote
unquote butt wink or you did a deadlift
with some type of thoracic or lumbar
rounding or you did an overhead press
and you have whatever going on you
didn't shrug at the top or whatever
that's why you're getting pain
perception now we've entered into a very
very different discussion where we have
very minimal to no evidence to stand on
to say that how someone doesn't movement
or what type of joint morphology they
have for completing the movement or any
of that is related to pain perception
but what turns out is the narratives
that we frame that discussion through
can reach far into the future and so
we've seen like qualitative analysis on
this where we sit down an interview
patients who have been given the
diagnosis of subacromial impingement and
we say well what do you think is gonna
get you better here and they say well I
don't know my ortho sent me to PT and
their time I need to rehab this but I've
got this bone spur that's grinding my
supraspinatus tendon down like what the
[ __ ] are they gonna do it rehab they
can't get rid of a bone and so and then
on top of that they think that they
shouldn't do particularly movements like
reach overhead because that's gonna
further impinge it and so these
narratives people buy into them and that
becomes a part of them and then it
influences their learned behaviors
throughout life and I would say that's
probably like as you guys can tell is
one of the number one things that like
really gets me going in the fitness
community is just making a lot of false
claims and false narratives around pain
experience as it relates to training
yeah I mean intuitively that makes a lot
of sense I mean I you talked about how
there's not one specific way to do any
particular time to type of movement and
like I coach a Special Olympics
powerlifting team and there's a great
deal of morphological diversity in terms
of joint structure and all sorts of
physical capabilities and so yeah I mean
that working with that population is
hammered at home that you know we've got
technical definitions of these exercises
and multiple strategies to get there
right exactly
so I I think my biggest follow-up
question to that would be like
well maybe it doesn't correlate that
well with with pain perception but as
far as so when I see people making
claims about like technique and and how
that could potentially be deleterious
generally they're they're making more of
an injury claim which a lot of people
then assume what is a claim about pain
which it very well may not be and
probably shouldn't be but for example
someone may say you know if you deadlift
with a bunch of lumbar flexion you know
that may increase your risk of back
injury is is that and so I also
understand that that there's not a ton
of evidence for claims like that but I
also wonder if this is kind of in
absence of evidence isn't necessarily an
evidence of absence type thing primarily
because like it's hot it's hard to
ethically study that in humans like you
can't really run a study where you have
one group of people you know dead
lifting with minimal lumbar flexion and
one group of people dead lifting with
maximal lumbar flexion and see like ohoo
ruptures the most disks like no IRB is
gonna sign off on that so like what what
what do we know about like not just
movement variability and pain but
movement variability and injury cuz I
think I think those are the claims that
I see made more often so it's yeah I
need more alcohol so injuries
interesting and I know you've done
research on this and I'm actively doing
research on it we actually just started
with that injury comes down how do we
define it and so like I always go back
to timki 2014 who defines it a lot of
different ways but typically in the way
I've defined it in my research study I'm
conducting is it's kind of a
multi-pronged approach a lot of people
think pain perception equals injury and
that would as you mentioned would be the
first false premise that I would highly
suggest we move away from that because
you can not do that and it turns out if
you think pain is
equals tissue damage and you avoid
activity you meet the injury definition
because you've you've self selected out
of activity and one of the main prawns
of defining an injury is decrement in
performance so if we already have a
misunderstanding of what it is an injury
you now have met an injury definition
because you've classified yourself as
injury which is a bit of a mind [ __ ]
of itself but if you look at it from a
tissue damage standpoint it becomes
tricky because now it's a question of
does it matter and if it does matter how
much of it and when and why does it
matter and it turns out like even if we
wanted to look at lumbar flexion would
say dead lifting and stuff or squatting
a it turns out that tends to happen
anyways regardless of how it visually
appears to your eye we're getting
flexion of the lumbar spine and say the
bottom of a squat and so that doesn't
matter does it make negative outcomes in
the long run which is the data we don't
have but it would be very hard for me to
say it does matter especially if you're
adapting to it over time because we're
living creatures we're not you know a
cadaver that matters because in that
regard that you are adapting because it
turns out that it's not correlated to
symptoms and this is where it gets very
interesting because you can have these
readily identifiable alterations and
you're completely asymptomatic and that
could be at any level of alteration to
the lumbar spine we have no way of
saying you're going to have symptoms
because of what I've seen on imaging and
that's directly related to how you
completed movement it turns out we are
dynamic creatures in a dynamic
environment to adapt to a lot of
different stressors and if we go like
the eyeless stasis rather it turns out
like the more capable you are of that
think that's the better things are for
you so just just to make this practical
just so I like fully understand your
position here so let's say you have a
lifter who they're competitive power
lifter so their deadlift max is
obviously very important to them they
they currently deadlift with a lot of
lumbar flexion like a ton of lumbar
flexion there they've tried lifting with
a
flatter back like there is probably some
flexion still going on but but
substantially less and they've tried
that before
and they're way way weaker would you
would you tell that person like oh
you're stronger dead lifting with a ton
of flexion you know you're you're
currently asymptomatic dead lifting that
way that's perfectly fine
have added like what what would your
approach to that to that athlete be let
me blow up the Internet
I would not alter anything with them
alright I'm famous if they've adapted
and is this a competitive power lifter
odds are they're training history has a
couple of years under it hopefully
unless they're just a freak of nature
and just destroyed [ __ ] you know year
one end they've probably adapted to
those positions and so it's gonna be
very difficult when we when we talk
about especially a barbell medicine my
kind of qualifiers for movements are can
you subjectively and comfortably find a
position that objectively allows you to
accomplish the task and so for the
deadlift subjectively uncomfortably find
a position that lets you lift the
greatest load now are there some
performance cues that we can give that
meet the criteria of objectively lifting
the greatest load probably but that's
gonna be individualistic to you and so
if you've been training that way you're
adapting to that way and I don't have
any evidence to come in and say that
this is going to be a net negative for
you prognostically speaking in the
future so there's no need alter that and
this even gets really really bad if we
come in and say [ __ ] like well your
lumbar spine is flexing you're gonna
have pain down the road I'm setting up a
negative expectation of Sivaji right and
that's what we really want to watch out
from doing yeah that that makes sense ok
so I I think that pretty much covers
everything we wanted to ask one last
thing scratch that right there's two
hosts now we've talked about some things
that you wanted to kind of expand on
things we've said in previous podcasts
now in a previous podcast we talked a
little bit
about applied kinesiology kind of trying
to make sure you leverage the energy for
minerals effectively when it comes to
strength performance did we at least get
the minerals right uh I don't recall
that uh the good news is there is no
right you can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want with your minerals Eric uh uh but I
want to get all the energy from it yeah
I don't I don't know I there any
randomized control trials of that yeah
so art we've got our content pretty much
scheduled out but for your site if you
wanted to maybe put together a guide of
which minerals to use for which
circumstances I know a lot of our
readers would really appreciate that I
feel like I should do this because I
think goop would probably contact me
maybe like hey would you like to come
work with us and I'll just sacrifice all
morals and ethics and take that money
but uh there yeah you could retire in a
year man right right yeah applied
kinesiology interesting dude I first
learned about it in Cairo school and I
remember listening to this and just
being like what the [ __ ] um but people
talk about doing manual muscle testing
in office and we do manual muscle
testing for if I'm worried about some
let's say lumbar radiculopathy where
you're having you know loss of reflexes
you're reporting
motor weakness to me and I want to do a
quick and clinic test is it the best are
there other things that may be able to
be done better would say like a
dynamometer for sure but manual muscle
tests probably aren't going away and so
that's normal things that we do to see
is there a neuromuscular issue issue
here in clinical practice applied
kinesiology does those manual muscle
tests but then draws just batshit crazy
conclusions from them like you have a
rotated kidney or you have high LDL and
we need to do this to fix it
I've sat through some of those lectures
and already and just like this I'm mind
blown like I can't even articulate words
for her for how to take away what I've
heard from those lectures so
neuromuscular deficits that are
inexplicably linked to the rotation of a
kidney right but I can prime you to fail
a manual muscle test right
so like it's interesting but there's no
there's really no way for me to
replicate the amount of force I'm
putting into you with any like type of
consistency or assuredness to say right
you know and then if I repeat it this
gets interesting because then you can
resist it there's you remember so when I
was growing up I used to go to the mall
a lot and there were these booths in the
mall with like energy bracelets and they
were like if you put this bracelet on
you're gonna be stronger and have more
balance and you know stand on one foot
yeah you guys on the necklaces - yeah
that's kind of what I think of it is
it's this is a whole nother podcast with
it clinical practice is a bit of a magic
show and it kind of ethically comes down
to the theatrics that are involved with
it and someone being in a position of
power and authority guiding someone else
through some problems they're having in
life and how much you want to feed into
these kind of contextual mechanisms and
placebo effect so if I'm really good I
can get you to believe things about
yourself and your experience fairly
easily right and this is where it gets
into the magic show and that tends to be
able to plot kinesiology seems to be
doing is I get you to buy into these
various ideas and thought processes
through my magic tricks and then we give
you some type of narrative that we need
to now fix now the parallel to this is
and ethically do we think applied
kinesiology is same better or worse than
me telling you your knee symptoms are
solely due to a torn meniscus and I need
to surgically intervene on that wow
that's a hot take yeah very hot take the
way that we like to end the podcast with
all of our guests is since you know this
is a relatively sciency place one of the
things we like to ask our guests is what
is something that either there's like no
evidence for or maybe even that there's
evidence against that maybe you apply to
your own training or like your clients
training that like you you just believe
is is there anything like that and and
you know and and just so it doesn't
affect your bottom line here let's not
talk about like your clinical practice
let's talk about your own training is
there is there something that that you
like to do in your own training and
programming that there's no evidence for
but like by God you think it just works
that's a good question I don't know that
I have an answer to that
I mean the quick easy things that come
to mind I and you guys may know this
better than me I put on a lover belt
when I squat a certain percentage I put
on knee sleeves when I squat a
percentage that's higher to me
anecdotally those saying subjectively
feel good and I feel like it gives me
some ability I have a feeling someone
like benedetti who studies placebos a
lot and as written on placebos in sport
would it be like yeah dude sorry that's
a placebo I'm not aware of Studies on
that have you guys seen anything um I
haven't seen much on knee sleeves as far
as belts go they do like actually change
some neuromuscular stuff one of the
things in now that I think about it it
could just be a matter of the subjects
being used to squatting in belts but one
of the things you see is that even with
even with the same absolute load when
people squat with a belt
rather than beltless you see like slight
increases in quad and hamstrings EMG so
it does seem like for some people like
belts do actually have like a
mechanistic effect of helping people
potentially like activate their their
lower body musculature a little bit
better but as far as the knee sleeves go
I haven't seen any research on that yeah
so that would be probably what I would
go with I don't do a whole lot man like
if squats programmed I walk in and put
the bar on the rack and start squatting
oh I don't know I like caffeine a lot
but I feel like that has decent support
maybe not you guys could probably tell
me that well you're in luck we just
published I guess yesterday a three
billion word article on everything you'd
ever want to know about caffeine it
sounds like my kinda article yes yeah so
I don't think I have a lot
I do but you know if I wanted to be
really kind of deep on this I guess or
philosophical we all have a series of
beliefs about the world and it just
comes down to what level of evidence do
you need to substantiate that belief so
I'm sure there are many things that I
currently do that will future will be
proven incorrect
makes sense all right man well I I think
that's all we have
thank you so much for coming on and now
this is the beautiful time of the
podcast where you can chill for as much
as you want tell our audience where they
can find you do you have any products
you'd like to plug etcetera the floor is
yours
oh cool something I'm really shitty yet
you can find me I'm pretty active on
Instagram
Michael underscore barbell medicine we
run a completely free pain and Rehab
subform on barbell medicine calm you
just click on pain and Rehab if you have
a question in there there's three of us
now or four of us that actually moderate
that Derek miles Michael Amato Austin
Brockie and myself and we try to give
you guidance that's completely free now
within reason if we think it needs a
consult will tell you we do remote pain
and Rehab consults we work with people
all over the world and as since we're
just trying to return them to the
activities that they have a desire to do
and we guide that path a little bit we
do completely free blogging similar to
you guys on Barbara medicines website
where I've probably written way more
words and anyone ever cares about to
talk about topics like what is mobility
and is it that [ __ ] we hear talked
about and being a supple tiger or
whatever um so you could gotta go there
and hear us just rant and rave about
that stuff I've done for products I
created some rehab templates for the
knee and as well for the low back and
then I just got done recording this past
week a seven module low back pain
clinician clinician course in essence
where I spent about six months looking
at the totality of research evidence on
what we should be doing in clinical
practice for someone presenting with
lower back pain
and then how we should be treating them
to get them back to the life they want
to do that I'll hopefully be out very
very soon and that'll be continuing ed
for clinicians very nice well thank you
for coming on and yeah I I think that's
a wrap thank you guys thanks for
listening to the stronger by science
podcast now Greg and I are not experts
in medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another healthcare professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it visit stronger by science
com to check out the products and
services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you